LOL
ờ ờ
ngoài này Thứ hai này có vài bạn thì
không biết vì nay là mình có thông báo
trên discord thôi nay là buổi
không hẳn là bảo vệ mà là thuyết trình
để mà mình hiểu qua được ý tưởng các
nhóm cũng như là ở
chữa chữa cho mỏng cá nhỏ mì cho đồ thực
thể và cơ sở liệu
nếu nghe rõ ông ạ Alo
thì thế nên là thực ra tôi cũng không
gọi là gần như ở chỗ nào để kiểm tra các
nhóm thôi cũng không yêu cầu các bạn vậy
Nói chung là phải những bạn khác thì
lắng nghe Bộ hôm nay được thì tốt nhỉ
Tôi sẽ tạo ở lên Google Mít để mày ông
tham gia nhé à
Ông hỏi tôi cái gì nha à
em nhắn từ đâu nhỉ
thông
tin nhắn Hải hay cho tôi trôi - tin nhắn
rồi bấm thì nhắn lại cho tôi chơi thử
tin nhắn thôi
Ừ anh
trình bày ý tưởng của nhóm nha à
em
khi lắp này có cam rồi đấy tôi á tắt
luôn hả camera
Em hãy thẻ xong không được nhìn thấy á
Ừ cái thằng gồm nghĩ rằng cứ tự mở lên
được thôi tôi tắt nào rồi khó chịu thì
đấy
ừ ừ
đẹp trai máy tôi vừa mở kéo phải không
trình bày ý tưởng ở
nhà phân tích
sơ đồ
ừ ừ
a Google hôm nay sẽ phân tích là cái bài
bản Đài Loan gần như thế
lịch sang 246 đâu mà tôi không thông báo
gì thì mày ông được nghỉ ở chuyện nhé
Chẳng qua là tôi hôm trước tôi chấm thì
thấy à Có vài nhóm phân tích rồi nhưng
mà tôi chưa hình dung được cái ý tưởng
mấy bạn ấy lắm nên là và lẫn cả đó Nói
chung là tôi sửa thì có thể đôi khi theo
ý thôi ông đúng hẳn ý mấy bạn đấy Thế
hôm nay chắc là cần một buổi buổi hôm
nay và bộ ngày mai nữa sẽ ra để phân
tích
và phân tích lại hỏi ý kiến từng nhóm
các nhóm sẽ nghe và rút cái nghiệm ở lẫn
nhau nữa không ạ nhóm nào
sẽ có vài nhóm chạy chung đề tài mà đúng
không để chuyện bình thường mấy ông đừng
có chọn chúng nó dai rồi mấy ông bỏ chủ
đề tài đi nha mà không sao thì mới tài
không sao cả tôi không so sánh việc vào
nhóm nào hơn nhóm nào đây cả À cho tôi
bảo rồi mấy ông quen dần việc là không
so sánh mình với người khác mà so sánh
mình với chính mình không ạ xem mình sau
trước cái đồ này thì mình như thế nào so
với đồ này thì mình như thế nào Đấy thế
là được
ờ ờ
Ẩm Thực ra là hôm nay nếu mà kịp thời
gian thì sẽ có thể
hỏi hỏi luôn về cái cơ sở rượu nhưng mà
chả không kịp đâu thì có nhiều nhóm phết
thiếu hôm nay cứ xem hôm nay có đầy đủ
cái hòm a bảo vệ không thì bây giờ cứ
lần lượt các nhóm xung phong đi mình sẽ
ưu tiên những nhóm ở đây trước đã nó rủ
Hôm nay bà là nhóm từ 1 đến 10 Nhưng có
vẻ Bây giờ mới có bầu bạn bây giờ Nhóm
nào nói đầy đủ ở đây thì cứ chia sẻ màn
hình rồi trình bày trước nhỉ
có ai làm đậu Thế mình
là no được không đã nếu mà mấy bạn đấy
Hôm nay có việc đột xuất không ngon được
thì cũng không sao thì một bạn à đại
diện trình bày cũng được để mà để mà
anh hôm nay sẽ chữa thì mấy bạn ấy Xem
lại video được nhưng mà cũng phải thống
nhất ý tưởng nha không phải mỗi ông một
tí thì lại cãi nhau à
hôm nay thì vẫn chưa đến phép tin nhắn
nên không biết thế
mày ông chắc cũng phải chủ động tìm cách
liên hệ đúng không
cha như trang đi đâu ý
rồi này hay là em cứ nói anh
Ừ ok em cứ chia sẻ màn hình em thử nói
trước đi Mày Nhóm kia nhóm nhóm Em nhóm
ấy nhỉ
À Ok ngắm một luôn đúng không về thì
mình làm một trình bày cho nha Rồi Chia
sẻ màn hình nhé ạ
Ừ anh ấy cũng chuẩn bị máy tính các thứ
để chia sẻ nói chung mở hết lên chưa
rảnh nhé á khi mở hạn chế Mở máy cái
nhạy cảm không tôi mất công tắc video ạ
khi các loại nền em thì làm việc phần
mềm mà quản lý phần mềm điểm danh thì sẽ
có 2 đối tượng sử dụng là gồm và quản lý
và giáo viên
nhà quản lý sẽ có các chức năng như sau
là quản lý ngành lớp môn học giáo viên
sinh viên và điểm danh giáo viên thì sẽ
có các chức năng là điểm danh thì cụ thể
là sẽ có thêm mới và sửa với điểm danh
không
thì lúc thêm mới thì sẽ có pallet luôn
là Ừ
cái này để đã thêm chưa có Xem lại lịch
sử điểm danh và xem lớp mình được phân
công Xem các lớp mà mình được phân công
để đi dạy à
chi tiết
em dựa trên các chức năng và thực thể
như này thì em có làm sơ đồ thực thể như
sau I
à à
sự
quản lý của em thì anh sẽ không phân ra
là thân là siêu quản lý với còn bình
thường nó để chung các phòng nghỉ luôn
nên là em sẽ có thêm một cái là lịch sử
để biết ai không tác động cái gì đó à
Cô Giáo viên sẽ thuộc về một chuyên
ngành
bộ công chức ngành thì sẽ có nhiều giáo
viên
môn và một môn thì có thể thuộc không
đến nhiều trong ngành môn mà không thuộc
chuyên ngành thì đấy là những cái môn cơ
bản và lớp nào cũng phải học và môn thì
em sẽ để có quan hệ của yếu lớp có hiện
được nhiều lớp
ở môn không ở chuyên ngành thì lại môi
mà tất cả cùng phải học môn cơ bản đây
Đang nhà em đại cương II
Ừ tại vì em thấy một số môn đại cương
thì
làm gì tục trưng này của mình
kok gọi anh nhớ rồi
Anh là môn thiền có quan hệ nhiều nhiều
với lớp à anh
em không có quà hỏi em để Moon quan hệ
nhiều nhiều lớp về em ghét thằng khóa
vào giữa
ý nghĩa như thế nào nhắn hay không hiểu
lắm
anh ạ
tin tức là khó thì thằng lớp này sẽ có
một trường là chìa khóa
quá thì em đang không hình dung ra là
tạo quá vào để giải quyết những vấn đề
gì đấy khám phá án tạo khóa là kiểu dạng
như là khóa khóa 1 khóa hay các ván gỗ
sau đó thì mã để phân biệt để về sau còn
Peter là lớp nào thuộc khóa nào thì nên
làm để hơn trong thùng nước này à
anh vì em thấy khóa thì nó thường là
giải quyết là ví dụ như là khóa một sẽ
học tầm 5 môn Hóa hay nó sẽ học hát luôn
đi thì
Ừ thì vẫn phải thêm chìa khóa còn em
chưa giải quyết cái điều đấy bằng cách
là em thêm môn mới
nên mới thế mà bị bớt modi
mới hẳn như thế hay là có thể tận dụng
lại muốn cũ nhưng mà nó giống hệt rồi nó
giống hệt như thế thì phải lưu lại là
mối quan hệ giữa chân nhàng với môn là
mối quan hệ một-nhiều
đầu nhiều nhiều rồi Em đang đểu đấy
thế rõ chẳng ngoan mà khoảng khóa cả và
cái chuyến nhanh Đấy cũng là chuyên
ngành Nó có thể liên quan khóa nữa
ý nghĩa là ví dụ là sử em ở
Em nói như nào cho dễ hiểu cho các bạn
vừa rồi nghỉ ví dụ Giả sử là cái dụ Giả
sử là ví dụ tấm như cái trường đi anh
Anh biết là em có thể đang ốp giống cái
chuồng VAC cũ đúng không Vâng Thì cái
chuông packet mình ngồi chữa lại thì
khóa khóa cũ thì sẽ học các chuyên ngành
của lập trình Nhưng mà đấy là trình cao
đẳng nghề này sau đó thì về sau có
chương trình mới là lập trình ở bên Nga
btec nó lập trình của anh cũng chẳng hạn
thì K để ra 2 chuyên ngành riêng rồi tôi
gọi lập trình nhưng mà hai tiếng Anh
riêng và nó sẽ có môn riêng có một vài
môn là kế thừa lại thôi Thì đấy là tạm
môn chung trên một chuyên ngành mới cho
mình xong tạo môn mới
chỉ có một vài môn sẽ Mới có vài môn vẫn
sẽ dùng lại và môn cũ tại thì nó cũng
không nó không nên quan hệ khóa gì ghê
cả trên mà chuyên Hoàng nó lại là gần
chuyên ngành thì nó mới lên Văn Khóa
nghĩa chân nhàng nó Nó kiểu dạy ở phù
hợp cho khóa nào với thử kiểu như thế cờ
ở Hải Phòng anh muốn thêm mở khóa Và đây
là để được
giải quyết là khóa này thì chỉ có vài
chuyên ngành này Đúng vậy Đúng rồi sau
đó thì lớp nó chạy có là mã khóa
ở lớp sẽ có mã quá
mở mã khóa và mạnh suốt ngày luôn cả hai
thì sẽ biết được là là lớp đấy học
chuyên ngành nào của quá nào Thế thì nếu
mà một ngành có nhiều ăn một khóa có
nhiều chân nhàng thì cái đấy để giải
quyết về bài toán gì đấy Khi to theo
khóa đâu em em bảo nó về sau được Nitơ
được còn thay vì mỗi lần là bây giờ anh
phi tôi là khóa 10 các bạn ạ Và 11 chẳng
hạn thì anh lấy cái khóa lấy từ đầu anh
lấy xe led sân từ trong là lớp ạ lâu rồi
mày không không ai biết
không ai làm thế đó Tại vì lúc sẽ ra
mình Chỉ lấy mỗi gốc mà chưa lấy ngày
làm gì không ạ
em không lấy khóa cơ mà để em ạ
nhiều về sau thay đổi thì mình sẽ tách
ra 1 cột 1 bảng riêng không gộp chung
vào trong một cột như thế được để mình
sẽ thêm một cảnh hành động phá vậy
cứ mỗi lần lên thêm một lớp đề chủ thêm
10 lớp phải trong 1 khóa thì chú nhập đi
nhập lại cái mã khóa à
Ừ
thì thay vì mình đi hay đi thì mình cũng
đi tên quá lên không ở thì nó tiện hơn
em
lại cả là không anh về sau không dậy mày
các bạn về xép trận đấu anh sẽ chỉ các
bạn cách để mà in search một cái danh
sách thì đó nhanh thế Sao anh có về sau
anh sẽ chỉ mấy bạn nha sẽ ra bản chất là
cái nói chung cho các bạn đang làm bên
nói chung các bạn làm đùa hay luôn này
bản chất là thực ra là bây giờ các bạn
phải Hình dung là giả sử là có sẵn dữ
liệu của người dùng và sẵn dữ liệu rồi
đúng không người dùng nhập vào trong cái
phần mềm các bạn làm sao tiện và nhanh
nhất thì cái việc là về việc là xinh giả
sử người ta người dùng có hẳn một file
Excel có 20.000 sinh viên rồi đúng không
đấy Chẳng hạn Huế người ta muốn import
và nhanh thì import ấy giáo sư người ta
có sóng quan tâm đến mã lớp là cái gì mà
mình phải render mình sẽ tự động tạo ra
mã lớp và tự động tạo ra gì đó thì thì
mình cần tự động tạo ra cái đấy nhanh
như thế nào hãy chẳng hạn thế ví dụ hồi
trước hồi mà Anh làm phần mềm à trường
luôn nhé ví dụ là khóa mới và đúng không
bên bên sale bên
ở bên gọi là
có sẵn một cái file Excel tầm 1.000 sinh
viên mới đấy bây giờ 500 sinh viên ở bên
lập chỉnh 500 sinh viên còn lại và viên
quản trị mạng và mỗi lớp về 30 sinh viên
là bạn
thì thì anh ngồi nhập vai thêm mấy lớp à
Không anh không làm thế anh sẽ chỉ cần
import và xong anh sẽ anh anh sẽ hiểu
Nhập là mỗi lớp bạn tối đa bao nhiêu
sinh viên xong rồi nó thích Xong rồi có
bao nhiêu à Anh ơi sinh viên ở biệt lập
trình đúng không bao nhiêu sinh viên bên
quản trị Thế xong rồi nó sẽ tự động tạo
mã lớp tự động tăng bánh số dụ lập trình
101 lập 902 1903 cứ để tự động đánh
chứ không sao mà lớp của các thần tượng
cao hơn lúc đúng rồi Sao anh nhé Tao bộ
sinh viên vào lớp ấy một cách Nội Yên
cũng được Hoặc là nếu mà cho triều công
bằng thì tống hết con gái không một lớp
rồi à
như thế nó giải quyết bài toán người
dùng là người dùng nhập em em cái này nó
nó mới đúng đồ ăn hay Nó là kiểu dạng mà
em phải hiểu thực sự là ngoài việc thêm
sửa xóa bình thường như đón một thì
người dùng bản chất là người dùng sẽ sử
dụng tính năng nào và tính năng làm mất
nhiều thời gian nhất của người dùng thì
cái nhập cái việc nhập liệu của em ý
không phải tiện cho cái việc đấy à
như
thế này anh mới bảo có cái mã khóa kia
thì em sẽ nhập dễ hơn nhanh hơn em chỉ
trọn khóa thôi Sao em inbox cho anh
khách vào nó nhanh hơn chứ không phải là
có sẵn lớp xong em nhập thủ công từng
lớp như không được rồi
Ừ Ok tạm bỏ qua Vụ này mình mình sẽ có
thằng điểm danh điểm danh ở nối mã giáo
viên mà lớp mã môn 13 phải không có phân
công ở không phân công và đã hiểu ra nhà
thằng phân công ngồi ôm body kiểu này
bao giờ đâu Em làm làm như thế nào thì
biết được thằng phân công lực tồn tại
vậy
à Tại em cứ nói là bằng thực thể yếu nên
là
à Hôm em gửi có cả thằng phân công thì
anh bảo là bảo thằng Quân không làm à
em không có hôm trước anh có hướng dẫn
các bạn vẽ ở Tân công rồi chứ còn nếu
làm gì như thế này em ra database thì
làm sao ra được làm sao ra được thắng
phân công
gì để mà bổ sung thêm trước anh có hướng
dẫn về cái vụ đấy nghĩa là em nói chúc
em vãi còn gì để mà người đang nhìn vào
cái này ra được cái bảo hơn công thì vẽ
có thể vẽ của anh có thể là lại không
đồng ý em em thể vẽ bằng cách gì đó em
phải vậy là được còn gì Nào đây thì cái
thằng không ra được mà
chủ đề về mục thông tin về
We are you để biết rõ điểm sinh viên có
điểm danh 10 đấy không
Ơ cái thằng sinh viên Lưu lại mãi dừng
Anh ở không đúng đâu mà thằng điện hay
là bằng yếu nhé
Anh hiểu Nhưng mà nếu thế thì thằng điểm
danh và lưu lại mã sinh viên chứ không
phải là thằng sinh viên nữa mãi hình ảnh
em tưởng cái ôm mà anh bảo là hai thằng
này là nhiều nhiều ấy đúng ngồi yếu ở
giữa thì một trong hai thằng sẽ ôm mã
của nhau đúng ôi nhưng mà nó là điểm
danh chi tiết không phải sinh viên chi
tiết
nó giống như là kiểu Hồi trước có họ hóa
đơn với sản phẩm ấy thì bản chất là hóa
đơn và lưu lại mã sản phẩm chứ không
phải là sản phẩm Đưa mã hơn đúng không ạ
về tình dục
khi
bạn hiểu không nghĩ anh nghĩa là bạn
khác à Nó nó vẫn nằm trong cái tính năng
điểm danh thôi đúng không có điểm đến
chi tiết của thằng sinh viên hoặc nói
mối quan hệ nhiều nhiều nó có tao thằng
trung gian đúng không
quản lý mỗi tình năng điểm danh thôi
nhưng mà cũng phải có những cái bảng
quan trọng bạn Chính nó chuyên ngày này
môn lớp này không Ok tạm thế đã ở mấy
cái cột kia thì anh sửa chữa sau quan
trọng Hình dung là được cái bảng đã
chữ
cái bảng lịch sử via gì à à
à à
tạm thời cứ để chồng là tạo làm xong hết
tính năng đã rồi mới cập nhật vàng ấy
sau nhé được à
ê kê Chắc ở thế nhỉ
Ok nhóm nhóm khác nhỉ
Ở đấy có mưa không
hi vọng đủ 10 nhóm nhóm Em ngắm em Ok em
chia sẻ màn hình
à à
anh thấy màn hình chưa anh ạ
Tải game thử anh ở Bình Dương à
Ở
nhóm em làm về chủ đề là quản lý website
quản lý đặt vé xe
cho hãng xe đối tượng sử dụng gồm khách
hàng
nhân viên quản lý
chức năng quang của khách hàng gồm Đăng
ký tài khoản Tìm kiếm tuyến xe Xem thông
tin chuyến xe đặt vé xe thanh toán
Online kiểm tra vé xe
xóa xóa thanh toán online
tính năng và luôn
hàng và hoàn vẽ sợ khó hoặc cho nó ghi
em tính năng nâng cao
[âm nhạc]
ăn nhậu không sót Tìm kiếm các tuyến xe
thị trấn xe đặt vé xe đặt vé vận chuyển
hàng hóa quản lý xe quản lý tuyến và
chuyến xe quản lý xe quản lý ngân hàng
còn lý tin tức quản lý sơ đồ ghế
và xem thông tin khách hàng
năng là quản lý trang thông tin bao gồm
Ban tuyển dụng thông tin về công ty quản
lý nhân viên trung tâm sẽ xóa đầy đủ của
nhân viên còn lý doanh thu theo tuyến và
các chuyến xe còn lấy tuyến và chuyến xe
quản lý C và tài xế xem thử Xóa còn lấy
thông tin khách hàng
tất sẽ là và phần tay để cho bạn kia
Thích Chân
Nam Nghĩa ở
Ừ anh thấy ở đây mấy cái có thể làm được
nhưng mà sẽ có một cái khó ở đây mà khó
thì mà kiểm quản lý kiểm soát được và
chính là cái vận chuyển hàng hóa với
cái này nếu mà em cho bạc online thì
thực ra thì em khó mà mức lộn được là
cái xe cái chuyến xe đến nó đầy cái chưa
để mà em có thể nhận thêm được đó trừ
khi ra Em dệt thủ công còn nếu mà em cứ
cho khách đặt bưởi rồi ông nào cũng đặt
chuyển se 334 xe máy lúc nào chuyển tấm
chụp cái thì say xe không chờ được đúng
không
em làm cho bệnh nhân viên mà quên chỉnh
sửa này
nhân viên hãy tự chốt lại thôi chưa có
thể này cái này nó khó hiểu mình tự động
được
tạm tạm phá mình mình cần làm bài toán
các bạn không cần phải ôm nhiều thì các
bạn cơm Các bạn cứ Hình dung là các bạn
phải vạch ra một cái mục đích ban đầu
đúng không các bạn đạt được với mục đích
ban đầu đã rồi các bạn nâng cao lên vẫn
làm được chứ các bạn không cần phải ôm
rất nhiều kẻ thù cùng một lúc ban đầu
hội ở đây bài 8 về quản lý xe khách đúng
không Nhưng mà xe khách quản lý xe khách
nghe nó rất là rộng luôn đấy mình bây
giờ chính xác là bài toán này chỉ tập
trung vào quản lý bán vé xe khách nó sẽ
bao gồm à là tuyến xe và chuyến xe như
thế này là là cũng được rồi đấy chứ thực
ra là mình còn chưa làm bài toán quản lý
nhân viên quản lý hoạt động nhân viên
rồi quản lý doanh thu có thử tao làm nhà
nữa đấy thôi Bạn định làm quản lý tin
tức này nữa vào đây rất được ra thêm sửa
xóa nhanh thì không sao giờ còn nếu mà
đi sâu vào nữa lại phức tạp nữa đúng
không thấy
cái nào rút gọn đi được Chút gọi em ạ Để
mình làm dứt điểm Song từ đầu đến cuối
một hàng sao mình lại còn phải tố ở chỗ
trọ sao cho nó kiểu nó tiện cho người
dùng nữa đúng không
Ok xanh sao cho đồ đi
Ok rồi anh
à Em em có phần sơ đồ Ok cái này cái này
thả là không phải thực thể luôn là
beauty Tail là tay rồi này cái này là ta
bây rồi
em có hình tôi bay với Tại vì sao cực
thì em làm chung của trọng này luôn
không không không hiểu tay rồi cơ thể
khác thì tao bên làm sao nói được
hả Bây giờ cho nỗi được ở một N1 nó thì
nói nữa ở nỗi mua đặt bé có dầu Nội một
nơi à Đúng rồi Đúng rồi Đúng mà ông nội
no no rồi ông nội nói đi ừ ở nơi em tất
cả bàn phím ăn xong Em nói một lời luôn
không không mà em
quay quay lại bên cái bên trong phân
tích bạn bạn chưa gửi lên cho bạn này
cho mất tích sau đó từ đó thì ra có
những thực thể gì cho
ở nhà anh em không nói em chứ
như thế chắc là bạn này cũng phải làm
lại đi làm lại cái tôi có thể Cái làm
làm nhanh nhạy đi xa ngồi tí khi thời
gian thì thì chia sẻ Sau nhóm nhóm nhóm
tiếp theo là tạm ngầm thứ heo
sao lại xem thông tin khách nhà hàng Xem
danh sách khách hàng thực ra thì ở cái
việc ra thì với tô con điểm Hồi trước
tôi cho đặt vé kiểu nhà ấy thì cũng hạn
chế cho tình đăng ký
đương nhiên là kiểu mình có thể xem lại
lịch sử cái gì đó e k thì nếu mà quan
điểm quan điểm của tôi nhá Nhưng mà lên
đặt vé với cái gì anh anh ấy thì tôi
ngại vụ đăng ký Tôi muốn cậu đặt gì đó
nhanh nhất tới để cùng nó xác thực số
điện thoại sao thực kỵ mail thì đó Thế
là xong đấy nó sẽ dưỡng già hơn nữa bạn
sẽ thức thôi chứ hạn chế kiểu thu thập
quá nhiều thông tin người dùng rạng ngời
tên tên số điện thoại nó có đủ rồi không
cần phải địa Trì không cần cái gì đó nữa
đấy Nên là các bạn à các bạn đừng có thu
thập nhiều thông tin người dùng quá hãy
hãy nên nhớ là người dùng các bạn vào
trang web các bạn bao nhiêu lần và sẽ
thu thập mấy cái thông tin để làm gì
không dùng để tự hỏi các bạn Thu địa chỉ
nhà họ chẳng có tác dụng gì cả đúng
không ạ Ừ ok nhóm tiếp theo còn nhỏ mau
nữa không
xem
tôi cũng chưa đọc cái đề đấy cơ Cái đấy
mới vậy
Em
có bằng lái ô tô đấy anh lo cho em ngắm
nói anh em đồng chí Ok Ok em cứ trưng
bày đấy
ở thì nhóm em làm về cho thuê xe tự lái
thì đối tượng sử dụng gồm quản trị vi ở
người dùng
đi nhóm em là ở đỉnh của đầu tiên là bây
giờ sơ đồ thực thể thì đầu tiên là khi
mà người dùng vào ấy thì người ta sẽ có
một cái bảng để nhập bảng với gọi như để
lưu trữ sân luôn là để nhập một cái địa
điểm muốn thuê xe này mới cả một cái
ngày bắt đầu một ngày kết thúc xong rồi
sau khi người dùng nhập cái đấy xong thì
bọn em sẽ sẽ lọc theo dưới hai mấy cái
dữ liệu nhanh nhất đầu mấy ngày kết thúc
đấy để so sánh những xe nào cũng hiện
tại trong thầy có Đã có hóa đơn trong
ngày đấy thì mới được hiện ra cô ấy
không thì sẽ không hiện ra
lớn uống
em đang cũng cái đoạn cái đoạn mà ngày
bắt đầu ngày kết thúc về một em hôm nay
hơi đau đầu
loạn đây đấy này Đây để anh thử nó nhá
quay quay lại bên A bên này thử nói Ừ
thì anh anh anh hình dung rồi Cái này
anh anh từng trợ sinh viên rồi đó là đầu
tiên là
ở đây người dùng của em là là gì người
dùng là bao gồm cả khách hàng cả amin À
trong một bảng nhưng mà
bởi vì là riêng khách hàng đặt váy xe
như này nó phải thêm chứng minh thư nữa
em ạ và
nó phải có thêm một vài giấy tờ xác nhận
đã bữa là em sẽ phải chụp lại phần mềm
giữ nó cả bằng lái xe thì ung thư Nói
chung là cái này thì à không thì ông thử
ra cầm đồ em đặt cái sai không biết
thật
ông Nếu người đi khảo sát thị trường chứ
có cái nó đúng rồi mà lý thuyết sai mà
thực tế đó là rõ ràng là em vừa rồi em
bảo là theo hóa đơn mà chọn sẽ là chỉ có
ngày bắt đầu ngày kết thúc thôi đúng
không
nên Nếu giả sử là người ta không trả
đúng hẹn thì tao à
có
này thì vậy sao sẽ có một cái trạng cái
em có đi lên trạng thái thì em lại sạc
trạng thái gì em anh ấy biết về cái của
trạng thái rồi nhưng mà ý là em sẽ không
biết được vào xe nào đang thực sự là đã
trả hay không
Nếu mà theo mỗi của chợ Thái thì trạng
thái bằng như thế thì em lại sai về cái
câu rồi nãy em nói là theo mỗi thời gian
bắt đầu thời gian kết thúc để biết được
xe rồi đang nó thuê được đang đứng thuê
không
Chứ
vào em hiểu ý
ấy thì cái bài toán ở đấy Đó là
và em cũng phải biết được là thực sự
ngày nào thì chả để mà quy ra tiền để về
sau còn làm thống kê với tàu nữa ấy thế
nên là ở đây Thực ra nó không còn một là
em làm theo cầu thuê ở đây Em đang thuê
theo giờ à
thường mà thấy ô tô thì thì lúc này để
thi thông ngày chứ trong ngày đấy thì
thì em sẽ ra kiểu không phải đi tha mà
chửi ế thôi đấy thứ nhất đúng không tiếp
theo là nó sẽ là
beatpad thì đúng rồi đúng không Nhưng mà
biết em và biết Huân ở Ngạn kiểu thời
gian thực tế chả tại Khánh ấy anh không
giỏi tiếng Anh lắm đấy nhưng mà nhưng mà
kiểu thời gian thực tế chả là ngày nào
đấy Sao Đỏ sau đó thì
notify đây tổng tiền đúng không Ok rồi
cay đi đi rồi Không nhưng mà đây nó sẽ
có hai Loser một là Jose đi làm áo kiểu
Zi đi làm admin người người duyệt cái
đơn đấy em à Ở đây chính xác là còn thêm
một người là người duyệt đơn lúc đầu cho
thuê vào một người là người duyệt khi mà
chốt khi mà nhận về xe
giấy tờ mọi thứ nó phải rất là sòng
phẳng như thế em ạ
là sao anh nghỉ bây giờ là một người là
Việt duyệt cái xe là đã được thuê này
sau khi mà người ta người ta thuê xong
thì sẽ không người khác Việt đúng rồi
đúng rồi người thu tiền người Việt đã
nhận cái xe chứ là đúng không thậm chí
phải có một bàn nữa bảo file Mình lưu
lại những cái ảnh liên quan giấy tờ liên
quan đến cái hóa đơn này và đấy khi ghi
mở Notepad lên đi mấy ông sao tắt nhanh
tay lên ông ấy có nhớ gì không
nên đừng đi xem lại xem
À hôm nay hôm nay đi giao Liễu Ừ rồi
Không không gõ kỳ thì tí ra lại nha Về
rồi
cái trạng thải này là trạng thái của đơn
thôi
trên ô tô thì ở đây slot là số chỗ à
hãng ra có nhiều cái em có thể tách ra
chỗ
01 chung cũng được không cần bạch bảo
được
khi mất bạn ấy cho phim tô dễ mà ứng
dụng là cái nhạc cái nhãn hàng kia cái
hãy em phải tách ra để về sau em hiển
thị từ Peter ở trên ta những gì đã sửa
nhiều với anh chỉ muốn chọn xe rồi rồi
rolls-royce rồi chẳng mấy đấy
A Z là cái gì nhỉ
xóa Bởi vì lúc đầu bọn em định kiểu cho
người khác cho Đạt xe cho cho mượn cho
công ty thuê xe xong rồi không cần tới
số tại sao tặng cho
một mấy cái mấy cái quy tắc chứ
riêng sợ không đủ chỗ quy tắc đối với sẽ
dùng sai á hay bị tắc chung thì nói
chung thì có thể à
em chả biết cái này đi nó mới ghi không
biết là đi ở đấy được không
chú phải lên hẳn vài trang thuê cho thuê
xe thực sự đi và và thấy thử em ạ bông
nó được
đúng không Tôi cho mấy ông tận hai tuần
chỉ ngồi phân tích không phải mấy ông
thủy phân tích như thế này vui đâu Mày
có phải thực sự đi họ ra đi ông bạn một
nhóm của em cũng bảo đi em rồi thử vẽ
cũng hơi run sợ tôi không biết tên thật
hôm bảo vệ thực tế là không phải mỗi
mình tôi ném đá mấy ông nhá là sẽ có
người các HR các nhà tuyển dụng và những
người chẳng biết gì về công nghệ người
ta cứ hỏi những cái mà người ta thắc mắc
mà người ta từng trải nghiệm rồi chúng
ta sẽ hỏi em tại sao không có ai Tại sao
không còn cái kia có nhiều cậu ấy ra mà
chả liên quan đến công nghệ không biết
lúc này mới không trả lời nha béo
anh chưa nghĩ đến chết đúng không
anh Anh không làm rõ mấy cái đâu nhá
những người kia thì người người ta đảm
bảo tuổi lớn hơn anh người ta sẽ hỏi
những câu gì gì đó nữa đấy
đây tiếp theo là giá đây là giá một con
sẽ
mua mỗi xe có một giá khác nhau với cả
giá giá thuê cho thuê một ngày sau đấy
cũng khác nhau luôn dọn giá xe nào ngờ
bán theo luôn À ông ý là giá đã thuê còn
như là giá để biết tất cả một cái giá
trong ngày
bản chất nó rất là giá cho ngày mà anh
cũng không hiểu gì Em
tính Chẳng hạn xe mỗi xe thì cô sẽ có
một mức giá niêm yết khác nhau đúng với
cả giá trong ngày khác nhau
thì nó vẫn là thuê mà em còn mua hạt đâu
Em có bán ở đâu mà giá như biết nữa
thấy không hiểu rồi Vậy ông từ khi ông
có giá rẻ đêm Hàn con mới nó là hỏng xe
của ông Em biết là có xe thôi là ở đây
thiếu nhá Nó không có giá phạt nữa
Em có phải là mơ
giá thuê giờ pháp khác nhau đấy nhá
ông tính luôn tiền phạt bằng thì thuê
thì nó cứ thể tha hồ mà vi phạm luôn
đúng không
Chứ bây giờ này Xóa đi
để lấy được những chú phải biết cách nói
không phải giá niêm yết chú thể bảo ra
lấy để đề phòng thằng kia mà làm gì gì
đó thì đến nghe nói chung à cái đấy còn
liên quan việc là chú về phải có những
cái quy định rõ ràng nữa có thể ở Chú cứ
bảo là em cứ quy định chung đó là
đó đó đó là kiểu dạng là nó mà làm hỏng
hóc gì thì em sẽ nhân cái phần trăm mà
người già niệm này để bắt nó đêm và đại
khá như thế chẳng hạn
như còn giá phạt thế ạ giáo khoa theo
ngày nữa
đây một cột nữa
sữa rửa mặt trong ngày nữa mà đúng rồi
comment gì trấn
Bình luận về cái xe như nào
thế phải bản riêng
đó là mối quan hệ một nhiều màn đúng
không
những tính năng gì nhỉ anh anh thấy thử
quay ở bên sang phân tích thích tính
năng của em Chị cũng muốn chỉ gọi như là
đau đã đăng đau đầu cái đoạn ngày thuê
Thế lúc ngồi thân thích cãi nhau cứ phải
đau đầu với lại
nếu đã cãi nhau vậy
cũng được cãi nhau sớm để tí về sau
từ sau cái hậu quá nhau các thầy cô sao
Ok
nếu mà chị đó là chị thuê nhà này thì
được các bài toán khó nhất của em nó sẽ
là vì sau để mà hiển thị ra được và xe
nào cho thuê Thảo không
thì ra là bên bảng khai của ông thiếu
đấy quay qua quay lại viên thực thể đi
của Hẹn của các bạn Đôi khi lầm tưởng ấy
chiếu cái cột ở cột sát
có phải có thêm cuộc sao top ở trong cái
xe nữa ông Thực ra là em em cái lúc đầu
là em bảo là
người dùng lúc đầu vào ấy sẽ nhật mà
ngày bắt đầu những ngày kết thúc để so
sánh với hóa đơn này
thuê xe đang bảo trì ra em sẽ bảo thì em
xóa đi à
còn xe Bảo Trí nữa nha Vào mà
trì luôn cả xe đang thuê thay vì em ngồi
cứ phải kiểm tra trong tất cả các hóa
đơn này em cập nhật luôn cụt status đấy
rồi kia nó trả xe thì lại cột lại chạy
cốt Cập nhật lại có status đấy không
phải cho thuê bình thường Lúc đầu của em
là chẳng hạn người mỗi mỗi một người
thuê xe sẽ nhập thời gian khác nhau thế
chẳng hạn Nếu mà cho cụ standard vào
trong xe này thì khi mà chẳng hạn người
một người người a này
chọn ngày thuê xe là từ 22 mốt à Ừ
nhưng mà người gầy người người b đặt sao
ấy thì người ta sẽ không thông tư tơ
được ra
thế bảo trì chỉ cần hơn 1 của bài chị
rồi
anh em hiểu cho anh
anh tự nhanh quên cái vụ đấy ok
chung em thấy cái kính hơi tính
không về sau ông chỉ cần thống kê là sẽ
xe nào đủ Face Nhiều không để đề xuất
cái nào lâu cũng
nói chung về sau có thể vẽ được Nhưng
tính anh lắm mấy ông được nghĩ ít bảng
có thể ý tính năng đoán hay nó sẽ tập
trung vào nhiều cái khác từ cái việc
filter của em phải Twitter thông minh
này rất nhiều và Twitter của em khi tơ
thì bạn giá này rồi này như kiểu mấy cái
trang sàng đập vậy à Trang đặt vé máy
bay đặt vé máy bay hơi
thuê phòng ấy em em lên Thủ mấy cái
Trang đấy nó sẽ có những cái chữ tô rất
là hai em thể tham khảo và nó có sẽ
Peter là nó có thêm nhiều cá thể loại
nữa cơ mà về sau em thích thì em để bổ
sung thêm ví dụ là sử là tao chỉ muốn xe
mui trần thôi chẳnghạn với ví dụ là ví
dụ anh vừa nói là thuê phòng khách sạn
nhé Nó sẽ kiểu phòng tao phải yêu cầu
phòng có hai Hường mà xong rồi cũng tắm
có gì gì đó với gần thì xe của em bản
chất là thứ cao nó có những cái đấy
không xe của em sẽ sẽ có một vài cái gọi
là phụ kiện ở hai phụ tùng của xe đấy
thì thì em có thể lưu lại thêm những cái
đấy hoặc không em thể lưu
xe sẽ mới sẽ cũ đấy Chẳng hạn phải có là
một cái thêm một cái tô rồi Vậy sao em
cứ chỉ là mày không theo thêm một đống
Peter nữa một tính năng nữa đúng không
nhóm tiếp theo thôi Cái
nó vừa rồi nó mấy nhỉ đồng chí nó như
thế
còn nhóm 4 Bảo
bốn kìa à
anh em nhanh bố mày chờ Thành ok
trò chuyện
ở đây là các tính năng động thì
trang web em làm là trang web bán vé xe
khách
vì thế nó gồm các
đối tượng người sử dụng ở là khách hàng
không có tài khoản ngân hàng thắt cổ bên
cung cấp dịch vụ và admin quản lý của
website I
Ừ thì đây là một số thứ năm
ạ
người sử dụng
transaction vé
kiếm chiếc là chuyến đi ở chuyến đi hả
Không có lại có chuyện có chị ở đây là
xe khách à
xe và xe việt Viettel là nhà cung cấp
the station là chậm dùng đến
a-prince à
thì em cho dù nhiều bến nhiều bạn đi và
nhiều tính
kinh tế và bên đánh về
bên Đức
Ừ Anh hiểu anh nói gì hiện
bên văn bản thì cho nên bạn bạn có chưa
là không không không bình tĩnh mình mình
cứ phân tích thực thể đã rồi mình sẽ suy
luận được ra cái ra tao bây sao Anh p
hôm nay xả chưa chấm kịp vào anh anh xem
thực thể em đừng có ra đó
đầu tiên em nói cho anh biết được à là
bây giờ là quản lý quản lý chuyến xe đặt
vé các thử đúng không lấy cái hình lúc
nó giảm đi nhưng đơn giản là bây giờ anh
muốn khách hàng đúng không đầu tiên anh
vào thì anh sẽ làm được những cái gì anh
tìm kiếm đúng không anh Anh tìm kiếm như
thế nào
thì thì ở đây em có chức năng là anh có
thể tìm kiếm xe yêu ứng với lịch trình
mà muốn đi Ừ
từ ngày nào đến ngày nào về đi tôi đâu
đến đâu nhé Đi từ lắm
điều chỉnh rồi quay lại bên thể khỏe
biết như vậy
thì Chuyến xe đầu chuyến chuyến xe đâu
chỉ về đâu mình em được thích đây cái
các hộp em lại mình sẽ ở mình sẽ tìm
tuyến xe và trong chuyến xe đó thích sẽ
có nhiều kích thích định là ngon mỗi
tiết kiệm là ứng với mỗi vị trí trên xe
đâu mà ghét vị trí ghế ngồi á
Ừ
thì ở tim mình mua mà chỉ mua thuốc
thì nó chỉ nói đến chiếc là chuyến xe và
Chuyến Xe tôi đã nói đến xe nào rồi nhà
nhà nào cung cấp
Ừ cái thông tin thế
để anh hình dung bên bên trang của em
Nga bảo là
ý
nó có nhiều bến Bến Đợi mình đón khách
vào bến mình trả khách xuống mà
Đúng rồi thì trong cái chai suất sinh
lời em cũng sẽ chọn
vị khách đó sẽ chọn một trong những kênh
đó là cán bộ ở
của em nha Càng ngày em mà có chọn nên
là chọn cái gọi là chọn là đi theo kiểu
từ địa điểm này điểm nọ là theo cửa cạnh
đó theo địa chỉ tại sao có đi Cine chuẩn
than biết cái gì chưa em
lúc trước mà em có tính là làm đi từ
tỉnh này đến thằng khác thì qua cái từ
hệ giữa thì mình cũng có thể đóng khách
nữa sao mà em không nghĩ đúng rồi
em thường ngồi xe chuyên nghiệp thì mình
chỉ nên toán cũng đâu rồi Tập cuối không
không không không làm thì ở lỗ vợ nói
cảm đó em yêu ạ Dạ thì em ra lại trong
nhiều trong một tặng nó chứ Mình có thể
có nhiều bến đến đón khách mà vẫn sẽ
khách thì sau đó mình tất cả tốt mà
nhiều khách có thể là đủ cho xe đó
Ừ
cái ra buồn em vợ ra 1 time nghĩa là cái
thời gian mà đón khách và theo địa điểm
mà mình muốn chọn đó
Ừ nó cũng nhớ là thời gian đến rồi đi
bến mà mình muốn đến hãng xe nói Thảo hả
chỗ bữa anh là anh chưa hiểu gì em à cái
xe cái kiếng đi này thì nó quen nhiều
vấn đã đón khách và qua nhiều Ừ nghĩa
nghĩa là nó vẫn là nằm tại bến nào đó
thôi mà đúng không ạ A2 ở đón tận nhà
nhà
cái này sai rồi đấy Cái thứ nhất thứ hai
là ông ông đang nghĩ phức tạp quá nhỉ
đơn giản thôi đấy nha nãy ở cách trình
bày em nó đang bị mông lông Nam bị loạn
cứ nghĩ đơn giản nữa đầu tiên anh có
chuyến xe đúng không đầu tiên thì thằng
admin nó phải tạo chuyến xe đã sau đó
thằng khách hàng mới lên đặt vé được
đúng không
vợ yêu chứ
anh em nghĩ là cái bên nhà cung cấp sẽ
tạo cho xe ừ rồi rồi nhà cung cấp tạo
chuyển đúng không nó sẽ tạo Nó sẽ tạo đi
từ ví dụ đi từ Hà Nội đến tận Sài Gòn ở
Ngạn xong rồi đi qua những đi qua rất
nhiều mến đúng chứ
đúng không Thì khách hàng nó sẽ chọn mà
tao đi từ bến này đến bến nào đó thôi
đúng không ạ
anh nhớ à là nó nó không có tâm với chú
xuống bến nào nó vẫn trả bảo vệ về giá
bằng nhau mà nhìn cứ thì cho nên em em
trai ghé vào nhau rồi bảo vệ muốn làm
cho nó có một tỉnh một cái này đến thằng
kia cho nên thì cái bến này là nó không
có làm chênh lệch giá như thế thì đổi
mới cập không Ừ thì bây giờ nó đang là
như thế nó nó bị chặn đầu tao thằng giảm
bớt tiền mày hỏi mày đi xe rõ là mày đi
trừ khi mày đi hẳn từ tỉnh này đến hàng
tỉnh mày muốn còn mỗi khi mà mày đi tỉnh
trung gian này được lạ tạo tao vẫn tính
tiền lại như cũ đúng hết
ấy thì ông Tại sao tự nghiên cứu sinh
cho thằng sẽ xin làm anh thấy chẳng cần
bỏ đi bằng bột này Thứ hai là cái Bến
đấy chẳng cần
Ừ chú khi em muốn lưu lại cụ thể là cho
người dùng là lại cái chuyện đấy đi qua
những cái tỉnh nào đó là một cái thông
tin để cho người dùng có thể biết thôi
Thừa Lưu lại tạo hẳn một bản riêng cái
đấy thì cũng cũng cũng được nếu mà cũng
Lưu lại để người dùng biết thôi cũng
không Không cần phải nó không liên quan
hình cái tiền mà đúng không nó không
thấy con lấy tiền nó không nên ngoan
việc là người dùng có tập được là từ bến
này đến nó 200 đọc được mà đúng không
Thì cũng bỏ đi cũng cũng không nghĩa làm
trẻ có cái bảng Bến đấy nó vẫn đúng nhá
vẫn không sai như ý nó chẳng cần phải
nói sao nữa nó nói đến mỗi và truyền đi
để biết được là chuyện này đi qua đến
những cái biển nào hôm trước
em lấy người dùng chọn đến đổ lên đi và
cũng xe được à
thế hả Chọn người ta chọn để mà ra được
cái chuyến đi thôi chứ không phải là
người đó chọn để mà ra được là vẽ đúng
nhất nhé Tao về vẫn theo - và đúng không
chuyến đi lấy vẫn từ tỉnh nào đó đến
tỉnh nào đó đúng không biết thì thì anh
ăn nó là cái chuyện đi nó vẫn lưu lại
cái bến thì vẫn có những ý là người dùng
sẽ sẽ thông qua cái hàng đấy để chọn ra
được cái chuyến đi và người dùng sẽ đặt
cái chuyến đi đúng trước và chuyện đi
như thế nó nó vẫn đi từ điểm này đến
điểm kia nó vẫn vẫn thế thôi nó bảo nó
cũng không
Anh sợ cái đoạn này à
dạo này để anh nghĩ sao ạ bởi vì là
thường là
thương lái nó cố định để chuyện đi cơ
chứ nó không có kiểu dạng như chú đang
làm đâu nó cố định đấy
khi lộ trình chuyển đi một ngày sẽ có
gì anh ở cái đoạn nó là cố định ví dụ là
ngày nào nó cũng đi từ Hà Nội đến Hải
Phòng thì bạn cứ đúng 1 giờ đến 3 giờ
ngày nào đó đi ạ Bây giờ Bây giờ em mà
tạo cái bảng Chuyến Đi do về đấy thì 365
ngày 365 Bạn ghi cái chuyện đi làm à
thì nó sẽ làm điệp lại đúng mỗi từ Hà
Nội Hải Phòng và cũng đúng và Điệp lại
từ 1 giờ thì bao giờ
anh
em hãy là em của em em cũng tạo lập lại
bạn gì nữa
Ừ thế thì thầm đồ dùng nó ghét phần mềm
của em lắm đó thà không dùng phần mềm mà
hơn
anh
em em hiểu cho anh không để mỗi một
chuyến đi anh nhá
một ngày có tận 5 phó chuyện như thế kết
hợp việc mà không phải một xe nó có 10
cái xe một ngày nó phải vào nó nhập thủ
công lần đấy Cái chuyến đi để người dùng
là Đạt đây thế Thế thì cái phần mềm của
em mới vứt Về chế tạo ra không dùng
em không nhớ để mình có thể cố định một
chiếc xác định chuyển đi
chuyến đi thì anh không rõ người Chắc
thần lịch chỉnh nó sẽ không bao giờ rồi
với tướng với những cái xe khách rồi nó
sẽ chỉ đi đúng với khung giờ đấy đi đúng
cái lộ trình đấy ngày nào nóng đi có vài
hôm mà không đi
một vài hôm nó sẽ có thể thêm chuyển
khác nhưng mà bây giờ Làm thế nào để làm
vụ đấy
em
nghĩ cái đó nên bỏ vào cái vé
chứ không phải vé vé lặp lại vẫn làm lại
thông tin hơn
nó có một bảng mình trình Lịch trình và
du lịch trình nó sẽ bao gồm cái giờ là
ngày đến ngày đi đúng như thế
các bạn nó sẽ em cần giờ cố định cố định
và nó sẽ có xe nào chọn vào cái lịch
trình đấy vào ngày hôm nào
đấy sẽ ví dụ là ông tài xế hôm nay ông
ấy có thể ông ấy đi xe đấy Ông về chọn
ông về đăng ký ở đi 5 chuyến nào ạ Ông
ấy và ông điền là ngày hôm nay ông đi 55
chuyến từ giờ này giờ này dài không tích
làm
ông chỉ thích cả hội và lưu lại đúng mỗi
cái ID của các chuyến đi mà ai đi của xe
hết
số từ đây nó sẽ có ID của cái cái cái
chuyện đấy đúng không cho coi khách thì
cần vào đặt cái chuyện đấy là con người
sẽ lưu lại ID Chuẩn đấy và Trọng ID của
bé nó xong cũng không như ở chỗ cơ Mấy
mấy ông cho đặt chỗ làm gì cùng lắm là
chỉ có đặt được vé ghế giường nằm hai
ghế ngồi thôi chứ năm cái chỗ ông ông có
phải hiểu vé xem phim rồi mà không đặt
chỗ gần cửa sổ đỏ anh
gọi em không để đó để bên nhà nên hết
pin có thể quản lý với cái xe đó cho bao
nhiêu chỗ ngồi để nó chia cái và giáng
sinh dễ không
fan của ông mặc định là lưu là có bao
nhiêu chỗ rồi mà và nó sẽ sinh ra bao
nhiêu vé
Ừ ông ông sẽ phải dùng cốt để ông kiểm
tra là xe mà đủ cho bé chưa Còn bao
nhiêu vé có thể bán được offline bao
nhiêu về đã bàn Online rượu chốt 1 giờ
trước chuyến đi là bạn Tao không bán El
like nữa một tiếng cuối là mày chỉ có
đến trực tiếp với mày Mày lên xe mày mua
về thôi chẳng hạn đấy kiểu như thế
có dấu hiệu gì anh không ạ
Ừ thế là em quản lý được khỏe thôi
anh
bị mấy cái kia bắt đầu biết phải bỏ đi
chưa bỏ bỏ luôn cả vết tinh nghịch anh
nghĩ em nó chưa hình dung được bài toán
này không ạ
ơ nhá Sửa chữa là cái thực thể này không
hiểu Thì cha anh sẽ nói thêm sau Nhưng
mà em hình dung được ấy chưa đó là mình
có một cái trình nó luôn cố định chỉ có
xe nó có thể thay đổi một hôm nay xe rồi
Xe này có thể đi được 5 năm chuyến Nếu
mà ngày hôm sau xe thì đi bốn chuyến
thôi
cập nhật bảng lịch trình vẫn yêu nó luôn
cố định để người dùng không phải ngày
nào cũng và nhập cái lịch trình đấy là
nhập khung giờ đấy nhập lại định trình
đấy Vứt
dùng không phải như thế đúng không phải
dùng chỉ vào tích xem và hôm nay tao đi
được vào từ 13 giờ 1 và 3 giờ 5 giờ thì
tao hôm nay thì đi hai chuyến thôi tài
xế sẽ người làm được rồi được không
để em nghĩ cái lịch trên một cái chết
của em cố định được không ạ
ha ha chế Cướp chỉ có kích thích ứng với
người dùng này nó mới thay đổi
thay đổi mà tùy biến theo điểm đến là đi
cái cốt nó nó thiếu đây thứ nhất là
thiếu xe nào sẽ đi này
đi xe khách kia đúng không cách kia thì
lại
Cho xem xe khách đi thì nếu nếu mà em cố
định bản chip đấy thì em lại say
Có ai yêu mà copy kích nó thay đổi á cái
thay đổi cái ngay á
Em thích ứng với từng khách hàng bốn đến
chỗ nào và đến về trận
điểm đến địa điểm đi khách xuống muốn số
lúc nào được đấy không quan trọng mình
không lưu lại rồi đấy
loại này quá
ở đây nha
Thôi để anh chia sẻ màn hình Anh cứ nói
cho
ừ ừ
ở trẻ em
hồ sơ đồ xe khách đúng không ạ
theo như anh chẳng hiểu nhà nha Để tìm
việc đi Chị sẽ có
ưu điểm
vì vậy gọi điểm xuất phát đi
ừ ừ
ở Bà Điểm
ở đó thì thời gian đi thời gian
Anh Đến
khi sex
3 kiểu nhảy lịch trình nào sẽ cố định
ngay nó sẽ có hai ở đây nữa này
thì nó sẽ còn được Nhân Mã xe này
Ê mày cái này đều có mã rồi bỏ qua đi
chỗ này quan trọng mấy cái quan trọng
nữa này
số xổ số ngày
bảng này nữa là Bà Nà
không - Đúng không sẽ là mã xe mã lịch
trình
cho Hải vật cái này xong rồi mật mã đây
nữa xong ngồi có bảng
chị sẽ có mã chuyến đi
anh alo lại thiếu nữa giới thiệu một
ngày nữa
bộ phim Quốc gia nữa đúng không xong rồi
anh chạy cái này thì khi anh bảo rồi tài
xế sẽ vào tích xe mà hôm nay chọn những
cái đi những lịch trình nào bởi vì có
hôm vài trong những cái ngay đặc biệt
ngày lễ ngày Tết rồi bạn lịch trình của
một mình trình nó sẽ dài hơn với ngày
thường vào ngày cuối tuần đi trình nó sẽ
dài hơn này hưởng với Biết điều đấy
nhiều không Ví dụ là bình thường mà chỉ
có ba truyền đi trong ngày bình thường
thôi nhưng ngày cuối tuần ở tận năm
chuyến cái ạ thì rất là truyền đi Nó sẽ
thay đổi nhiều con lịch trình thì ra nó
vẫn chỉ có những cái cố định như thế
nghĩa từ không chờ từ 10 rồi đến gì đó
thôi đấy thì cái tài xế nó vào nó sẽ
tích vào hôm nay sẽ đi những cái lịch
trình nào đấy Sao từ đó sẽ sinh ra đừng
lần nào cái vé
theo cái số chỗ của cái xe đó chị sinh
anh lần nào với bé Thấy chưa tôi chú sẽ
kiểm tra trong cốt là cái chuyến đi này
theo về số chỗ này thì có đủ vậy đã có
đủ người chỗ đăng ký vé chưa về mà khóa
không cho gặp vé nữa lại thay như thế
thôi
Ừ ok chưa ạ
Ừ thì biết là giả sử là nhưng mà vừa rồi
bảo là khách hàng lên có thể là là kiểu
chọn là đi vào hôm nào và có lịch trình
nào ấy thì thường là nhà xe nó sẽ thường
này đăng ký cái cái nhà xe thường ai
đăng ký trước một tháng sau nó vào nó
bằng thì ah nó tạo hình lịch Chuyến đi
so sánh sau được thế thường Lấy trước
một tháng để mà khách vào thể xem được
nó thường anh chỉ cho đăng ký chỗ một
hàng ơi nó không cho em kín sớm hơn quá
đâu cho không Bởi vì nó lúc đấy nó tạo
lên trình cũng chỉ một tháng chứ một
tháng sau rồi đấy chứ
tự như vậy thì lập trình đó có nhiều quá
lịch trình nó ít mà chuyến đi là mình
hiểu rồi chứ Linh trình nó có vẻ ít thôi
nhưng nó chẳng đọc ngẫu nhiên điểm xuất
phát của chị đến hả Đi chùa rằng cái rồi
nha Ở đây có Hà Nội
ở Hà Nội điểm cuối là Hải Phòng chẳng
hạn nó đi qua mấy cái bến nữa vừa nãy
còn nhắc về bến đúng không Chứ có bến ở
đây này
ở đây sẽ có mã và địa chỉ thế thôi
Á và một Gallery này có sẽ có nhiều bến
để biết được là đã đi qua những biển nào
hết
thì chủ tìm kiếm là kiểu là kiểu bến nào
bến nào bến nào thì nó sẽ nối nối từ
bảng này đến bảng lịch trình để biết
được ở lịch trình nào đi qua những cái
bên đấy thế thôi I
Ừ Ok chưa anh ạ
Nghe nhạc ngủ say sưa cái này thì nó có
lịch trình thì nó còn điểm cuối nó tính
những cái điểm đó ở giữa ô
không có điểm giữa điểm giữa Chị ơi cái
bến này nữa toàn bộ những cái bến là
điểm giữa
cho ví dụ nha Để Hà Nội Hải Phòng đúng
không Rồi đi qua một cái tỉnh là nó tỉnh
ở đó thì những cái tỉnh lấy là cái bến
này
3:00
số lượng khách giữa đường khách lặt vặt
thì ông vẫn phải mua vé giá vé vẫn thế
mà vẫn bản chất là như thế này cơ mà
thực tế là đặt vé xe thế này đểu chuyên
nghiệp chuẩn thì nó khó ăn dụng được tế
với cái cái kiểu mà Nhật khách giữa
đường lắm Bởi vì rõ ràng là có thể đặt
sự vé xong hết rồi nhưng mà có vài ông
về bến giữa rồi tự nhiên có thêm vài ông
nữa lên rồi lúc đấy cũng không biết sẽ
vé kiểu gì đâu ấy nói chung là cặp đặt
như này rồi giữ chỗ thôi
ở truồng à Thường là nói chung nhà mấy
cái xe bây giờ thì cả khó dụng được thực
tế ở Việt Nam vẫn đôi khi đó quá có kiểu
quá tải mà chị bình thường
ừ ừ
khi mà khách thì là cũng không quan
trọng vấn đề nữa khách mà lên dọc đường
thì khách cũng được miễn là tao đến Được
điểm của mạng của tao chứ tao cũng quan
trọng gì đâu ạ
[âm nhạc]
nhỉ
Ok Ok
theo gọi là kinh nghiệm thì chưa chắc
phải dưỡng chưa Làm thế này nhưng mà tôi
chữa theo hiểu quan điểm của tôi ông nào
góp ý ông góp bị hoặc à không chưa nghĩ
ra cách để góp ý
vài ngày sau góp vì cũng được không sao
tôi thấy ổn thì tôi sẽ nhắn tin cho nhóm
này mấy cái nhóm này để cửa sau nhé ở
hiện tại tôi thấy là cái cách đấy về cơ
bản nó ổn mà không mấy ông mấy ông hiểu
mấy ông Nếu không hiểu được cái Dạo này
không Đã nó Nó kiểu
hiểu kiểu dạng kiểu theo Bến Cát những
thứ được Mà
khách nói khác xe buýt về bởi vì cái
lịch trình này nó dài hơn so với xe buýt
Còn nếu mà làm thấy cậu sẽ biết thì tao
lại sang bếp đấy nó là lịch trình đối
Khanh
ông đặt vé xe buýt online
không chạm được lắm tiểu bây giờ rồi cố
định được những xe khách đâu
Ừ
ý là tôi nhóm em luôn anh Ok Ok Ok nhạc
Giống mẹ nó cùng chuyến xe rồi
Ok Anh nhớ rồi ngắm số mấy nhá
Để Nhớ thứ bảy
rồi nó trình bày
Ừ thì nhóm của em nó không à nhất của em
không có lịch trình nhưng mà
để em trên đây đầu vậy mà về phần chuyện
của em có chuyện xe là
có một chiếc xe và trong chia sẻ đó sẽ
có
sẽ có xe hai cái này sẽ sẽ ra một chuyến
xe sẽ
sẽ là sẽ có một một cái một chiếc xe
trình bày giống như vừa nãy anh bảo ấy
đó là
khách hàng lên trang web nó làm những gì
từ đấy nó liên quan những cái thông thực
thể nào thì em sẽ trình Béo dễ hơn dẻo
kể khách hàng để trang web của em sẽ tìm
theo
điểm đi và điểm đến Tức là tìm theo ra
từ ướt ở và tìm theo cái thời gian
Ừ bắt đầu
thời gian của
ký chuyện xe đó và
điểm đi Điểm đến của em sẽ
được gọi là sẽ lưu ở trong cái bảng
quyền xe
và bảng Tuyết xe này còn ở điểm đi điểm
đến thì quên thời gian đi thời gian đến
thì sẽ lưu ở trong bản chuyến chuyến xe
thì một bảng Chuyến Xe này sẽ à
kết nối sẽ có liên hệ
một tuyến xe thì có liên hệ nhiều với
chuyện xe Tức là ở
ví dụ như là điểm đi từ Hà Nội tới Hải
Ừ
thì a sẽ có nhiều chuyện xe như vậy
một một chuyến xe thì sẽ có nhiều chuyện
xe
có một tiền xe có nhiều chuyến xe thì
anh hiểu
a tiếp theo là bạn à
bảng dai vợ bạn này là bạn của
tài xế em vì không tạm bỏ qua mày gầy
không máy cày
anh nông dân kẹp Em em em Cái quan trọng
nhất em là tuyến xe để anh thử hỏi lại
cho kỹ nhé ví dụ là bây giờ em em em cứ
ví dụ là cái bảng bạn bớt cho em phải
lưu gì bản router bus em sẽ điều gì đi
dễ nhà chồng mà bản cho tôi bớt thì em
sẽ lưu địa điểm đi và điểm đến em nói
nói thẳng là em lưu lại giá trị Giả sử
có một cái gì đó
có một lộ trình gì đó đi
Lạng Sơn Hà Nội Hà Nội đến Hải Phòng Hà
Nội hàm điểm đi và điểm đến trong này sẽ
có thêm là thời gian hoặc thời gian đi
từ hai địa điểm và khoảng cách giữa hai
địa điểm A threat một mình lưu diễn
fz1 là điểm đi
cứ cái này em
tức là lưu bến bến sẽ còn em có một em
rất hay là để lưu cho địa chỉ của KTM
hoặc là user ở anh em chưa về vợ ở trong
này
nhỉ
bàn fz1 thì lưu lại location em ạ Còn
bảo Custom mờ kia thì ghê cứ Atlat ở
được cái
xe sẻ đối với một một chiếc xe
thì
Tức là trong cái chuyện xe đó sẽ sẽ
11 Chiếc xe sẽ vận hành
và một chiếc xe sẽ có ở sẽ có một sơ đồ
sơ đồ ghế
sơ đồ ghế này dùng để cho khách hàng lựa
chọn với những khách hàng để chọn ghế
của mình ngồi anh ra các bạn cứ làm vụ
này phức tạp và sâu bọ tạm bỏ qua với
ghế phạm ghé em ạ
trước kia cái Sao em có ghế vip thì ra
nó không có chọn gì cả Chỉ đơn giản à Có
bao nhiêu vậy bit và bao nhiêu vậy
thường ạ Cũng được còn mấy cái khác bỏ
qua cái cái này thì em chọn là chọn cái
vị trí ngồi đi
rồi Tân dưới hoặc tăng tiền hoặc là ngồi
ở phía trên hay là ngồi phía dưới của
chiếc xe cho
Ông Phước bà của em cứ tạm bỏ qua mày
Cái gì ạ Cái bảng bớt này lưu lại cái gì
có em thử ví dụ mà thằng bớt này nó
giống như là một sự kiện á Nó là một
chuyến sẽ giống như là ở
và bớt này nó
nó có thời gian xuất phát
nó chỉ có sẽ thấy Tức là
nó giống như một sự kiện là nó Đạt đo
chuẩn bị chuẩn bị diễn ra hoặc là đang
diễn ra hoặc là
nói không rủ đi này ví dụ thôi ạ ví dụ
như là chiếc xe từ Hà Nội tới Hải Phòng
xuất phát từ 12 giờ ngày 16 tháng năm
chẳng hạn thì đó là một chiếc xe còn một
chuyến
ở đó là một chiếc xe thì có khung giờ
khác thì nó làm ở bến xe mới
Nó nói là nó là chuyến xe còn cái kia
lịch chỉnh Lộ trình đúng không Đúng là
cái cái cái này là lộ trình còn cái con
cái này là một chuyến đúng không Mẹ cho
con lúc này
tên Bảo bị bị loạn quá
đúng chứ là cái bạn ấy hiểu sao được
hình dung những cô chỉ
có trong chiếc xe này
ở trong chuyến xe này thì sẽ có cây
Ok
router và driver Tức là nó sẽ có một lộ
trình và một à
anh tài xế rồi một tài xế ép em sẽ nối
hai cái này vào một bảng riêng để đập
Mặc dù trong một tài xế cho một lộ trình
riêng luôn
tiếp sẽ là bảng xe cột xe và tiếp theo
sẽ là bảng để bắt đầu tham là khi thời
gian xuất phát
kia đến là cái giá giá iPhone là giá
nó cố định còn cái giá axit amin này là
khi giá để ạ điều chỉnh giá số với cái
thời gian sự kiện Ví dụ như Elise hạ thì
mình sẽ tăng giá lên
em
ô ô ồ vậy à
trước khi em muốn hiển thị cho người
dùng thấy rõ cái gì rồi thôi
em là nói là
cây Chuyến Xe này đang xuất phát này là
gì
đang diễn ra hoặc là bị hủy hay sao đó
đó là sự tốt của bạn này
chị sẽ bị hủy ỉa ra cốc cũng có chiếc xe
bị huyện này bị hư Ok nhưng mà còn đang
diễn ra thật ra mình dựa theo cái iPad
và Apple time sẽ biết rồi nghỉ hả
Chạy
biểu đồ xít Nói chung bỏ mấy cái ship ra
đi
tiếp theo bảng vé sẽ nối những cái gì
nhỉ thì bằng với em đối với trưởng ý em
nói VSIP quay lại nói với chuyến xe à
anh nói chuyến xe
Anh đi chưa hiểu rồi Sao mà
rồi
Ừ đấy thì cái xe cái xe lưu lại thêm mà
số chỗ ngồi đúng không ạ xã cái diagram
đi
ạ Đã rằng và cái Đài Loan vẫn làm sao
cái xin đi ăn
cái tiếp theo bảng bưu hóa đơn
cách làm mờ và sẽ nấu với bảng thích
thích luôn Nhưng mà em Kiên kết nối các
đoạn này là đã phải Bill sinh trước thì
tích cực hay tích cực Chị xinh cho bưu
những cái kẹp chỉ là thức đi Thế bị
ngược đấy
đi vệ sinh mà chưa thích thật chứ
đã nhớ lắm chị à đương nhiên đặt vé
nhưng mà đưa nhưng mà bạn sẽ là những
cái về cái cùng thuộc một cái đơn chứ
chúng không em thể đăng nói nhiều vé
không Lúc mà đúng không Nè đâu ạ
em
có cưới mời đi này cốt có là gì nhỉ
À cốt là kiếm cái mà để cho khách hàng
lên ta
trả cái cái cái bưu của mình Tại vì tụi
em làm là khách hàng Khách hàng không
không cần đăng ký tài khoản
khách hàng có thể lấy cái mã code này để
lên cả cái bưu của mình dùng để hủy vé
hoặc là xem thông tin chi tiết của vé
của mình
hợp lý nhé ok rồi đồng tiền này đây mình
mới hết bỏ qua
bên dưới để lại được về chơi cho chuyển
khoản được sao tốt đi AD có ai đi rồi
em không biết bà nhưng mà thôi trong
càng
trước khi về sau ở cập nhật thêm so sánh
nhiều sau Tết thì để như vậy không đưa
lại trong i5 là được rồi ờ ờ
a
game ever 2 IDE file này mà bỏ đi
Mình lưu lại hẳn Atlas a
cho khách hàng được rồi trừ khi ở về sau
chủ muốn lưu lại quán một khách hàng có
nhiều Atlat thì chú mới phải tạo của
thằng bạn riêng thôi
chuyển khách hàng thì thôi nhà chúng mày
ơi bà bầu và thị xã
ừ tạm hơi thế tạm xóa hai cái shit kia
đi này ờ nối lại các thử này không
thì ta là thường mà anh thấy tài xế nó
nối đến cái xe luôn đấy chứ không phải
độc lập như em đang làm không Nó để anh
xem à đó mà tài xế nói tới chiến sẽ
không nó nó là lái xuyên mãi không phải
rồi thì sẽ nó sẽ khác đấy Cái chỗ
Nội
cha mẹ có ID của driver
sẽ hiểu và cái để chuyển đi thì còn có
ai đi của xe thôi không cần ID Viber nữa
bạn nói thế nhỉ con trình bày gì nữa
Giả hết đấy
ok
ok ngắm đi nhanh nhỉ A mixed hôm nay thì
em ta Tối hôm nay tôi dùng không không
dùng để mic 3 củ mà dùng con tai nghe
kết hợp với chửi tôi nghe các bạn nhiều
hơn nói mày sắp phải thịt ngay tạm được
thôi như có ông thì đang bảo là nick tôi
còn xịn hơn mọi hôm rồi không hiểu lắm ạ
nếu Nãy giờ đang bàn về vụ gì đấy
nay mới chữa được có mỗi 4 nhóm gì vậy 4
nhóm
36 nhóm mà lại tôi rồi
Chắc là nhớ em này ok nhóm em nhóm ấy
nhỉ em này
ok bắt đầu đi ạ
Ừ
game mà
của sinh viên trong trường đại học
cấp độ ý kiến này sẽ có
sunmin đó Vụ thằng điên là sinh viên sẽ
rất Minh đã phụ trách các vấn đề liên
quan đến các dữ liệu và các tài khoản
mới cho người dùng đó vụ thì sẽ xem điểm
và thống kê điểm để tạo file giấy có thể
hai giấy chứng nhận các kiểu giảng viên
Thì được phép chấm điểm mà xem điệp của
môn mình phụ trách cho các thiên nhiên
mình dân sinh viên được phép xem profile
của ba số điểm bản thân
Ừ
thế là như này giết người đau vụ thì
khá là độc lập
chưa có
chưa có thể là một hệ
ngành nhóm
nhóm rồi đấy đó tâm đừng đừng nước ạ
chỉ dùng để
tức là em có thể để cái cách trích xuất
được cái thực phẩm khóa riêng đúng không
đó thì khóa riêng trước đó ra được ờ Nếu
mà bỏ cái mã khóa ID thì em có thể trích
từ cái mã nhóm ra mãn nhãn cho gồm cái
cái là sẽ có gồm cả mát pháo đấy có thể
chết được không Không Ai Làm Thế cái tay
cái tay ra đấy khách hàng riêng ai đi
để lúc đầu em định nhờ để theo một cái
tắc đặt tên cho mã nhóm để có thể tách
được cả khóa là cho tôi đây là cái cái
cái cái đấy cái đấy thì anh không nói
cho nó nói vẫn vẫn phải để phía sau mình
làm Peter cứ dễ Các bạn cứ lưu lại cứ
tiết kiệm làm gì vì sau mình làm từ điều
phải lưu lại ra hết
tiếp theo là ở đây có môn này có mã sợ
rằng viên à
Vì theo ở đây thì sẽ là một giảng viên
có thể dạy nhiều môn mà mỗi một môn cho
từng nhóm này có thể có các thành viên
khác nhau dậy ví dụ như là nhóm số 1 thì
giảng viên a dậy và nếu số 2 thì bây giờ
ở bên B tại môn đón như màn 4 của ông
còn nói nhóm ông nối với ngành mà
em muốn nó cũng rất là một cái này một
có thể thuộc nhiều ngành mà muốn cạnh
hơn nữa nhiều môn để em quên mất không
nói với nhóm nữa không em Em làm nó rất
là bị loạn em đang bị loạn
Ừ anh mừng về đây con thế cài đặt này
từng năm học
thì vừa nãy giống như anh chữa giống như
là anh chữa cho các nhóm hát thôi nó Nó
là kiểu à
bản chất nó là nhiều Nhiều tất cả đúng
không
có khoa khoa độc lập này này nhàng thì
độc lập này
ở nhóm mà cái tên
tên của nhóm ở rồi Nếu mà nếu mà lớp đấy
thì nó lại bị sai về mập môn Nội thuộc
mã lớp không Không có khái niệm đấy
hai môn luôn ở đây
giống nhờ anh thương ấy chia cho
anh anh anh chữa rồi đấy đó đó là tiểu
một ngày thì có nhiều môn và một môn
thuộc nhiều ngành mình không lưu lại mãi
ở trong môn muốn nó độc lập môn có thể
hoàn toàn là học ở ngành này có thể học
ngành kia có thể học khóa này học khóa
kia vẫn bình thường mà chả có gì em cũng
không có lưu lại ở gần nhà nhưng mà chửi
đó em không là nghĩa vụ mà một đảng viên
đối với một môn thì mua cảnh đối với các
nhóm khác nhau có thể thành khác nhau
cùng là một môn nữa
giảng viên có thể lưu lại mã ngành
há mồm nữa mã ngành mã ngành
nhưng mà 11 ngành Mã ngành thì trong một
ngày người có thể có nhiều nhóm khác
nhau cùng học một cái môn là giảng viên
đấy chỉ dạy cho một vài nhóm nhất định
được
mình mình thấy cái là Cái quan trọng là
mình có muốn lưu lại cụ thể là giáo viên
nào dậy được chứ mua nào hết không Còn
nếu mà mua em muốn thực sự muốn lưu lại
phải đi lấy nữa để một tiện làm việc vì
sao đề xuất thân công thì em phải tạo
độc lập cái môn mà Giáo viên hệ dậy được
lưu lại ra một bảng ghi âm nó không liên
quan thì việc là thằng Môn phải lưu lại
mã hoàng viên thì không được
cái cái đấy lại liên quan đến việc mà là
mối quan hệ giữa giảng viên với môn là
giáo viên có thể dạy được những môn nào
chứ không phải là giảng viên tạo ra môn
Nếu mà em yêu lại theo kiểu mã như kia
giống kiểu môn phải phụ thuộc vào giảng
viên thế là sai rồi Chắc là môn Anh bảo
rồi môn được là nó không có lưu lại mãi
mà nào nó độc lập nó tạo ra sau đó thì
thằng Chứ ngành này mà có những cái mô
nào thì nó là một quan hệ trung gian nữa
hàng đấy à
Ừ
rồi chứ
phân công hả
chẳng ghi này dạy môn Toán
giải thích chẳng hạn cho nhóm A nhưng mà
nhóm là khi mà chỉ có thể chấm điểm cho
các môn giải thích cho nó bê được vì
không dậy được phạm trù giáo viên khác ạ
để phân công làm gì liên quan đến tôi
chấm điểm là nó hơi làm nhà tao tặng lúc
nào là cái này là em bị loạn rồi thì rất
là ý tưởng hay là các bạn riêng để nồi
quan hệ của giảng viên môn vào nhóm
Nhưng mà mẹ lại đi thẳng của tao với
thằng Môn này đặt
xuống cái bang này bị sai rồi ông lại
bây giờ lên rồi em ạ 10 cái quan trọng
của kìa Em em đang nghĩ nhiều ý tưởng
quá trong lúc thiết kế em em phải anh
Anh bảo rồi Ngay từ lúc đầu em em có
những hào trước để tạo những thằng ấy
trước thôi em mới tính dần các tỉnh năm
sau đầu tiên là khi mà người khi mãn Min
Vào trang của em nó sẽ tạo những cái gì
trước sẽ tạo khoa chức tạo ngành trước
đã khóa trước tạm môn trước đây sau đó
thì nó sẽ tạo ra lớp dựa theo những cái
gì cho nó tạo giảng viên xong rồi tạo
giảng viên dạy được những môn gì sau đó
nó phân công Đây sau nó thì về sau giảng
viên vào đăng nhập vào thì nó chấm điểm
theo kiểu như thế nào nó sẽ chọn cái gì
chấm dứt điểm
ấy em em phải trả lời đúng ở câu đấy cứ
chứa săn lại Hứa cái này anh chữa rồi
bây giờ chả bạn một ôm lại rồi đấy hai
bạn nghĩ về ý tưởng mới thì mấy sau nha
Cái này sai rồi à ở bên phần quản lý
điểm thì sẽ có
rất là sổ điểm nó sẽ có mã kỳ Học mã môn
bất Đảng viên và điểm số
nó sẽ lưu theo kì học để mà có thể xem
kia khi sinh viên xem lại thì xuất hiện
hơn ạ Có đền thống kê là kì kì một mình
học môn này điểm như này thành viên 2.0
Thế tại sao về cột mà nữa thì mã để đua
mắt hổ điểm trong sinh viên
sang diem diem mã số điểm à
Ông nó sẽ bị ngược ấy nhỉ
Ừ cái này có thể lưu hướng rồi mã sinh
viên ở đây không không phải có thể lưu
mà nó bắt buộc phải thế rồi Em làm thế
Lại làm sai cái gì Em làm thế thì một
sinh viên chỉ lưu lại một kỳ học à
à chết là đúng rồi
nào là em đang bị loạn nhé Em cư hình
dung xăm
hình dụng đã tao bây xong mới đến sơ đồ
kể là sai nhá hình chung sẽ thể được thể
mối quan hệ giữa sinh viên với điểm Nó
là một nhiều vào cái làm điểm nó phải
lưu lại mã sinh viên mà
lưu lại một mã đâu vì bản chất nó không
nối hàng nào nữa không cần nói lại cuộc
đấy toàn bộ những cây cột kia nó sẽ ra
quả chính này thì học mã môn mã sinh
viên Mã giảng viên không được cái mã
giảng viên không cần Hoàng Trí Ừ thì có
khi học mã môn và mã sinh viên là phải
chính thôi
[âm nhạc]
đánh dấu đi Không phải quên em rồi chết
rồi
liên quan đến vài chục thể thôi cháu đi
còn gì đâu nhỉ Tặng người chắc chỉ có
vậy thôi
ông không có dặn dò vụ
nó vụ gì em chưa có Trình bày chức năng
của nó các kiểu đó đã muốn in lỗi nó chỉ
rất để xem ấn tượng và giá trị rất thông
qua các kỳ chức năng thống kê và mình có
sẵn cho đội nhé
Ok Ok
Tạm nơi ấy đã nào trò
nghỉ
hết nhỏ mới nghỉ còn mấy ông đa ngon đấy
nhớ này Ok Ok Nhà em nhà mấy ngày 26
Ừ Ok hôm nay trình bày chưa cũng được
ừ ừ
đã những nhóm dưới số 10 còn còn ở đây
không nhỉ
đến 10 ngày ngày hôm sau thấy chữ nốt
nhà có thể
nhóm nhóm em số mấy Ở số 8 đúng không
sao đi còn nhưng mà cứ trình bày trước
cái ý tưởng mình chứ đấy ạ
Vậy à
a
gameshow mở máy cẩu
ở
được inspector thầy dạy đọc đăng lên tự
lại tự đăng lên sẽ tự chỉnh thời gian
đầu đó sẽ là được tính theo buổi cho mỗi
tao sẽ dạy trong bao nhiêu tiền học
trong bao nhiêu tiếng đó
driver này sẽ là
học người học còn tin thì cái file này
sẽ là
hình ai thì giá để làm hồ sơ
thích
lúc lên thì nó sẽ như
du lịch sử các buổi học đó thì trong đến
sẽ có đánh giá luôn nên nó sẽ tính theo
giờ học này
từ giờ học để tự sẽ có thiết kế toán
tính ra lương
và sẽ ở Hội Thánh sẽ cậu ở đây đi lấy
cái đâu này nó sẽ tự cậu lấy từ cái này
cậu vào cộng vô nào
để đợi anh chị Nga nghĩa khóa học của em
em em cứ thử nói ví dụ là dữ liệu thật
đi đầu tiên thì khóa học của em em lưu
lại là Part sẽ lưu lại ví dụ là gì
Ví dụ là 2 giờ chiều nó hay giờ chiều
rồi ví dụ là out sẽ lưu lại 50 tiếng đàn
không
sợ không nói lại thì một trong một bộ
Anh ở trong một buổi ý à bốn tiếng nữa
rồi rồi rồi ah đùa đấy
ngã nghĩa là
cái này là buổi học đó Đây là buổi học
ngoại khóa học đúng không
Ừ rồi đấy nó có cái phụ nữa đây là người
học nó sẽ để đăng ký khóa học trọn gói
thương không Hoặc là đăng ký của buổi lẽ
cái khóa trọn gói thì em làm là biết
được thế nào trọn gói
thì tùy vào lúc người ta đăng ký người
ta đã đăng ký nhưng mà em yêu lại không
ra bay của em thế nào là trọn gói còn
gọi là bao nhiêu tuổi
em lưu lại kia là khóa học thì thì nó
khác có đêm lưu lại Em rảnh chưa biết
được là thế nào một khóa của em có bao
nhiêu vậy
nó khóa là hai mươi tuổi
ông ha cốt điều đấy ạ Hai ông đâu Cái đó
hả
chồng nó sẽ trong đây cho giới hạn
driver 20 không
để ông hót cốt thì á Ông còn lưu lại
trong da bây đâu
mỗi không Điên à Không ai làm thế phải
lưu lại phố mình mình sẽ phải có một bà
mã khóa học 1 bảng bảo mua ấy và cái
bảng buổi đấy chính là cái bạn lock lên
đi kìa đấy bà khoa học vẫn giữ nguyên
bảng và lachlan kia chính là bán buổi
học đấy và mình lưu lại số giờ trong đấy
về chưa
dễ thương và khoa học nó không phải làm
nữa có bao nhiêu buổi như đâu mà bảo đâu
mà một khóa đấy nó sẽ học cho mà bao
nhiêu tiếng đấy thì nên anh mới bảo cái
ao Kia có phải là đúng số tiếng hay
không Này xóa của startup đi
của Sulli Nếu mà chủ thuê của giảng viên
cái thì không không cần nói chỉ thế thôi
hãy sau đó thì cái log lên rồi là kiểu
đã từng buổi đúng không Buổi anh chẳng
biết từng anh là gì nữa
nhà mình sẽ lưu lại Aoi trong đấy nữa để
biết được buổi đấy thực ra mình sẽ dạy
mấy tiếng
10 đêm đến thì em sẽ phải cao cao ở
trong cái bản kia chứ
anh không lưu lại trong DB rồi đấy vì em
có thể đếm được Em có thể đếm được cô vợ
lặp lại driver ai đi lặp lại bao nhiêu
lần em đến thì thôi
đúng không em Em dùng hàn để em dùng hầm
cao em để được em không có thể lưu lại
thêm một cột khi mà có thể tính toán
được một Đấy
thêm một cậu iod ha
ở định dạng như là em sẽ theo vào đây để
chị như đủ sức sức sức nó sẽ giảm dần
lại
không Nếu bu nó thì sẽ không có cao cao
để luôn còn
nếu cái phu này là vô nó thì sẽ cao hết
20 buổi xong 20 10 ông lấy ở đâu như
kiểu là hồng chẳng ai làm thế cả
Bây giờ anh bảo rồi lưu lại ở đây bởi vì
rõ ràng là có thể một buổi của em nữa
đâu Hôm nay em rảnh em học bố tiếng nó
có hôm em thì học mỗi 2 tiếng một tiếng
thôi em mua khi em đã lưu trong khóa học
kia dịch vụ 50 tỷ hướng hạn thì em phải
học đủ 50 giờ đúng không Thì cái kế khóa
cái buổi học của em nó cũng phải cộng
lại sao cho đủ 50 tiếng em vẫn phải lưu
lại cao dồi trong từng buổi học
không không đếm được rồi em bỏ qua cái
đến không cần đến
học rồi
giờ em chỉ cần đến tổng tổng số giờ này
mà bằng cái tổng số giờ Khoa Học tức là
em học Đủ rồi Tại xong đấy Còn cái việc
mà em đăng ký full trọn gói không ấy
đúng không em Em đang muốn làm về thì
đang ngồi đúng không đấy thì sẽ không
thì được cái là em có 1 file ai kia rồi
mà
biết được á Không như thế thì cái cột
thêm một cột đỡ cho anh ở bên cái cốt
cái kia phải hai cục mình ra một cô là
của file giá Một Cột là Viber
gì đấy Ở đây Cái gì đó
kiểu em từng buổi chị sẽ là bao nhiêu
giá Kia giá trọn gói còn giá từng buổi
là bao nhiêu yêu đâu vậy nếu như là
người học người ta đã không Mỗi buổi đó
người ta không thích học Anh đang đăng
ký trọn gói đó nhưng mà là mũi này tao
học người này người ta có buổi sau tao
không thích học người trước nữa người ta
Hồng người khác
thì cái cái
in ID girlstory sóng trong bảng khóa học
với
đúng không
chồng buổi từ buổi thì vẫn có người
người kiểu hướng dẫn riêng mà đúng không
Trả chưa kìa
đúng chứ
trợ của fala game Xóa đi Harry đấy em
phải đưa lại trong Index cho mới đúng
bởi vì à giá lương của một ông luôn cố
định tại một thời điểm còn về sau khi mà
cập nhật thì giá ông ấy lại thay đổi
khác phá cô để đi này vứt cột đấy vào
trong con in trong bản in Roger này và
cái em một tính lương cho ông đấy thì nó
nằm trong Monster di rồi a
cho Total series riêng Hãy pha dứt rồi
nào thì sao
Không phải buồn hay không ai không ai
đăng kí hộ học không thì ông ấy không có
nướng thì thôi
Đây em sẽ có toselli kia tôi tôi sẽ đi
ô tô series Total War đúng không Không
có xa đâu xa rất là sai
anh Em không có nói gì cả bạn ấy không
chỉ có nối injectors Tôi không muốn nối
thêm thằng nào đấy nữa không ạ
out ra em ở đoạn này có thêm một cái sai
nữa đó là em mà đăng ký full như này Thế
giờ xử xin học viên đăng ký tập 34 lần
đi học thì sao nó chuột rồi đăng ký hơn
phát nữa cho chị em lưu lại cột full ghê
Gọi chị
Hai em bạn một driver mới
tạo một driver mới
chất là cái phun kia nó không có ý nghĩa
gì cả
anh
em như thế em phải lưu lại code sai đi
vào trong bảng trong cái thằng driver
mới đúng
Ừ
nếu mà nó có code ID tất cả lắm truyền
nó sẽ đăng ký full còn nếu mà không có
sai đi để Tức là nó đăng ký theo từng
buổi
bình tĩnh và này đang hơi khó để mình sẽ
bạn đoạn này đã vỡ cái loại đấy Dạo này
đang bạn nhá bình tĩnh khóa học này là
khóa và có nhiều quá phải không
trọn gói hay là học từ mỗi theo như đề
đó Ừ thế thì đã không có hẳn mới thấy
không có hằn bảng khóa học và trừ khi ở
về cho mình thay đổi giá nhiều Đợi anh
tí nhé thay đổi giá thay đổi số rồi nữa
Ừ vẫn vẫn luôn có không không không sao
nếu thế đấy nha driver ở đây bạn Full à
ở lại là có sai đi
sao mình còn tính tính bao nhiêu người
đăng ký khóa này đúng không đăng ký khóa
này không hề biết là cơ bản đây hay gì
đó
mình vẫn phải thêm một cột nữa là cột
full 20
lít phun đi nói chắc iPhone
ông hông Drive cho bả vai cô ấy đi full
biết được vào xem mọi người đấy và đăng
ký trọn gói không
ít Nó là kiểu theo ý
à nhầm Nó là kiểu ít kiểu là buôn lần
buồn lần này
SS SS đ
chuyện chơi nha Bây giờ bài toán ở đây
đó là
I had Min tạo một cái khóa học đúng
không Ok rồi này sau đó thì
đi qua for virus 50 dầu này giá dầu Tổng
cộng là hai triệu đồng ạ xong rồi
một
1100000 một buổi được ạ một ngày buổi
cái gì đó đúng không đó thì khách hàng
vào đăng ký khóa đấy đăng ký full được ạ
Chị sẽ lưu lại là ít phun một này có sai
đi thì sẽ lưu lại thì cốt vào đúng không
Bây giờ ờ nhận sau đó thì khách Hà đi đi
từng buổi thì sẽ là lưu lại trong lock
lock đúng không là lưu lại level đi này
yêu lại người hướng dẫn này lại và ai đi
buổi này nếu mà lưu lại đi buổi cái này
thì có khi không cần nữa bởi vì có sai
đi mình lấy từ driver đi rồi bỏ đi này à
à report ở đây là kiểu sinh bắt cá phải
buổi học rồi ok sẽ Viber báo cáo về buổi
học đó chất lượng như thế nào
ghi review đi
thế Xóa cái cột có ai đi đi nếu mà mình
có có sai đi từ driver rồi
thúc 1 tháng thì mình sẽ tính tổng lương
đúng không theo từng giảng viên một mình
sẽ kiểm tra xem à Khó những thằng thằng
injector nào có lót trong tháng đấy thì
sẽ thống kê ra là số dầu là vì xong rồi
lấy cái cột seri nhân với số dầu ở để ra
được cô tồi Fairy thế Sao ghê chưa
nối nối lại cho đúng là được
Em có còn người học lựa giờ thì
sao Nếu lại xong ghi tát vào trong rock
ta rất ở đây là bao gồm ngày luôn để
biết được là gì mà thống kê được là
tháng hai tháng ngày có bao nhiêu người
học đúng không Để cũng thống kê được vào
tháng ngày có bao nhiêu người dậy luôn
thì mới tính được cho tổng tiền chứ
không Máy tính của lương
rồi Vậy là cái trang web đó
em đi khảo thép sẽ khảo sát thủ thì nó
không có khác các trang web chị như vậy
luôn
hả Sao em như nào
giải quyết đăng ký khóa đăng ký bằng lái
xe thế này
Mà theo em nhỉ Ừ
nó nó đầu tiên này nó vào nó sẽ chọn cái
gì anh Ai cũng chưa Tôi nói với vụ này
đâu em đi kiếm khỏi cũng không không có
thực tế không không có trang nào là đăng
ký cái khóa chờ nghe hay như nào không
có em đi kiếm không có nó chỉ là những
trang cơ bản liên hệ số điện thoại là
không có đúng rồi này đủ rồi nó không
khỏi sáng nào như này thì thơ ca là cái
này Nói chung là bây giờ cũng có vài cái
gọi là một cái đây rồi một cái kiểu dịch
vụ kiểm dịch vụ này Thực ra nó cũng
không
thấy ra nó cũng không đã Hả mình về công
khai nó cũng được dạng là không chuyên
nghiệp lắm phải không Thấy không chuyên
nghiệp vì nó vẫn do phát sinh cá nhân
thôi chứ nó không ai ví dụ từng ông
hướng dẫn từng cá nhân không tự mở ra
các chữ thứ chứ không phải có hành một
lò rồi mà đào tạo
đúng không Đúng rồi đấy ạ thì mình cứ
làm như tuổi chuyên nghiệp thì nó sẽ
tương đối là như này thôi
Đây là
người dù người ta vào người ta sẽ đăng
kí vậy Đăng ký từ buổi học cũng như thế
nào
ra bỏ bớt vài thông tin đi được không
sao
người dùng không thích anh thì nhiều đó
nó bớt phải thông tin mình Chỉ cần vài
thông tin cơ bản thôi
rồi chứ
bỏ tao cái đó thế nào gọi là dễ như
thông tin hồ sơ
xin lỗi vợ Thế thì chú lại thiếu thông
tim dại như mình là một cách trung tâm
luôn thì cái đấu này nó sẽ là thông tin
về Western xuất ra cái để làm thuốc làm
hồ sơ thi luôn á à anh ấy lại thiếu
thông tin chứng minh thư nhân dân nữa
ai đi thật đấy
đi 5 bộ file ra để thẻ
ID number chứng minh thư nhân ra đã anh
còn không như anh không nhớ tiếng ai gọi
đâu em chưa biết kĩ đây dùng với các em
được cái đó
buổi học tiếng Anh là gì nữa Lúc lên
nghe Nó cứ phơi khô cái cái
cái
thì cũng đến trình sửa được các con
không không không chỉnh sửa đâu
lexin bạn kia thaurissan cũng hay buổi
học từng buổi học mà Jackson cũng được
Ừ
hết rồi
ok con nhóm nào nữa không nhỉ
nóng 26 à
26 anh
ông vẫn chỉ có em ok cho ngày hôm chị
Bảy nói đi gần hai tiếng ơi rồi không vì
ngày mai ngày mai tận hạ cũng
Hôm nay có vào nhóm muốn còn chưa trình
bày nữa mai theo Tận 20 đến nhóm nữa thì
không biết bao giờ nữa à
gái không nhớ đây tài số mấy đâu
về điểmtrang điểm danh Ok
biết chỉnh lấy cái thành này kiểu gì
không Sao em anh cũng quan tâm đẹp hay
xấu đó chuyển bé em thích em sách có thể
đừng cái kiểu che cả lót xong rồi là
mất nó vào một cái bạn có tên đường
riêng có cái chết mẹ trả góp ý
a clock là cái gì nhỉ sao nó kiểu slot 1
là từ mấy giờ đến mấy giờ phá thai mấy
giờ đến mấy giờ
trưởng em là chơi theo kiểu chekhov
cho nó 1 2 3 4 Nó giống trổ ca đúng
không chúng ta Đúng không Vãi ka ông
dịch thu slot
cách để
đến này không cần em Quên sửa Bởi vì
trong nữa thì đừng có đến sẵn rồi ngồi
mẹ chỉ còn như này không
à à
à Xong rồi à sẽ khoảng vào cái attendant
to
thì nó sẽ có biết là thứ hai thứ ba bốn
xong rồi nó có slot này sao lót này nó
này
anh tĩnh bình tĩnh nhá
[âm nhạc]
Đảng phân công ở Em đâu
bảo sơn công ấy em chưa có em với chị
tập trung ở cái tên là nếu không
Ông vẫn người có đúng không
Mai em để mua tiếp
Ừ mai nữa thôi
không phải tội để ông Mai ông mới chấm
Cái
lesson buổi học cũng là một cái hai này
hết xuân này có chất hack clash nằm
Braxin à
Ừ cũng được gì Cái cái trình cái phân
công chứng nhà đất Sơn đây mất luôn cái
thích cho ai đi vào trong về dưới Xuân
được
chứ trời đi vài giờ nữa đúng rồi
đúng không Không phải nối nữa đúng không
tính em rồi sao thì em sửa lại Trình bày
lại
đây
chắc có lẽ nằm ở dưới một cây cho nói
nói
a cho tôi định ra kẻ attendant này nó nó
phải lưu lại Xưa nay đi giống như về anh
gọi chữ là một nhóm đấy
Cái điểm danh nhé em nghĩ ở trong cái xả
lót là có từ đừng ai đi sẵn rồi thì nào
nào lại linh tính đó khác nha
nếu vậy thì bỏ tiên đến ID trong sao lót
rồi thêm tôi đến nay đi vỡ trên đời này
ừ ừ
ở đây đây ở đây ở đây kìa
đúng không được vậy sao được gì trong
mạng lớp thì trong sự học sinh là có rồi
đúng rồi
thế nhưng mà khi vào chủ điểm danh thì
thì chú ạ
Ừ chú chọn lớp mà đúng không chọn lớp
phải ra để anh để anh Tình Cho
Không cần thiết
Ừ anh hiểu em anh hiểu em chọn chọn sim
chọn đá
à à à ơi anh mới thấy xưa đến nay đi ở
trong slot Ok Ok
lót ở trong slot đó là gì nhỉ em Em định
lưu như nào em đã yêu theo kiểu là
1234 sẽ Note 1 Note 2 Note 3 lớp 4
ôn định nối là một cái bảng riêng nữa là
slot 1 là từ Dạo này đến giờ này nữa
không Không có lắm thế
nhà mình có thể cố định giờ cũng được có
đi đâu ở nhiều trường sẽ cố định luôn
Giờ nói thỏ trong cốt cũng được
ở đây cái cái bảng slot của em cái sư
đừng đay đi này em phải Hình dung là nó
là ờ
đừng nói cách riêng là thằng nữa đúng
không Nó là no nê với thằng xưa đấy à
chưa một học sinh Sao lại không được
trong nhiều rõ được nguyên học sinh điểm
ra nhiều lần trong cùng một ca á Không
phải Đúng rồi trong cùng một ca Bởi vì
nó có liên quan đến ngay đâu
trong cùng một ca biết slot 1 là từ 7
giờ đến 8 giờ thì chỉ có một học sinh
đấy là xong cũng một cái đấy chứ ngày
hôm sau nó có ở trong từ 7 giờ đến 8
được không
Em có coi con
thấy chú thấy đại này chú đang bị loạn
không ạ
Ừ cái của em đang bị sai cái cái đoạn
này liên quan được những ai và cái slot
rồi đấy và em truyền hình dung được rồi
đợi đấy
chưa Nhà mình tĩnh đi tính e đã nói xong
đâu thế vẫn chưa Đúng rồi nhá Thế bạn để
nối rồi
bình tĩnh bên Theo chú thì cái sợ nó để
lưu lại cái gì và cái A brandon là đúng
chưa để hình Dung để anh hình chỉ chủ
két thì dung đơn giảm khi mà khi mà sinh
viên đã điểm danh nhá là phim mà Giáo
viên là điểm này nhá giáo viên vào điểm
danh nó sẽ chọn môn và nói chọn lớp
chuẩn bị đã đúng rồi sau đó nhiều địa
danh trái sinh viên đúng không Đúng rồi
sau đó giáo viên bấm điểm danh không nhớ
rồi thì nó sẽ lưu lại và những bảng nào
và mình cần lưu lại như nào để cho nó
nhẹ nhất nó đỡ lặp lại dữ liệu mở Excel
đấy mà mời khác đấy ạ ừ ừ
lưu lại có những bảng nào lưu lại những
cái gì để cho nó đỡ lặp lại và nó dữ
liệu có về chuẩn
Ý em là vào lớp trước đã này
lớp 1 đúng không Trong lớp thì có môn
không có nghĩa mình lưu lại đi nó cứ tạm
bỏ bỏ ai bị không không đưa lại ai lớp
đúng không Bỏ đi bởi vì em mình gọi lưu
lại ID tư đền rồi đúng không Ok gọi đi
vào sắp là có Nghe danh sách học sinh
luôn
Cô Đơn
em ngồi chơi đi có rồi
nếu đại Gõ lại đi
đấy nhà đẹp đúng à
anh khi
bắt đầu bị loạn đấy
em hãy cho anh nha à
của chủ đã đúng không ca đúng không Tiếp
theo đi trời đi này
rồi sắp chạy ngay đi Đúng chứ Đúng rồi
thì làm thế nào biết được là đã điểm
danh lớp này chưa ạ
[âm nhạc]
à mình mình dựa theo tư gần đây đúng
không
Bây giờ
đè bảng ở thiên đúng không Đúng rồi ạ
Thế thì chú sẽ thấy là lót hết ngày một
sinh viên như này tôi là sửa là destop
đã tình trạng sinh viên hôm đấy Hôm đấy
sinh viên đấy năm chẳng hạn
nguồn tt em ạ Cho anh được ạ cả một hạn
không như này ra xử như này đúng không
Đúng mà thôi slot cũng là một chỗ mà anh
cũng được pp
Bình được ạ một ngày
và ngày hôm nay học ngày mai ngày 01
chẳng hạn đúng không Đấy slot này làm
lại đúng chứ vào
à à
Ý bạn nói hiểu hiểu ý anh không
Bạn này sai lầm như này sẽ làm làm này
làm sao biết được thằng này nối Thằng
này
nó quay gì Nói chung là thằng này à
anh nói hôm qua flash thì Ok để em Nếu
là k cũng là một xong rồi nhưng mà giáo
viên khác dậy và muốn khác thì lắm à
như này thì giảm
tỷ lệ 4 cột cùng là khóa chính luôn
bố cục không nói chính thì bốn còn lại
phải ôm theo bên này để nói lắm không em
về cho
hạn đúng không ra sự là có một mã tự
động tăng đây nhá
một ai đi để hạ đúng không
Chứ nó đi một hạ hai ba nha
nữa em em thấy có Visa đâu không thấy
thông thái nối sang đây thì này sẽ ai
dysport đúng không ạ
ở đây một là lỗi ngày nhưng mà thằng
Bình học cùng tháng năm cơ mà Tại sao ai
đi đó là thành hai
lại là bạn như này à
được bản chất là cái slot Ở đây nó không
lặp lại nghe thằng sư đời này đi Sang
tuần này đi nó mới và thằng bếp này nó
ra ở đây Đúng đây này đi nó ở đây đúng
ở Quy Nhơn status Mạnh xe ôm xuống đây
này Đấy à
ở nhiệt độ nào không
Thế nên vừa nãy anh bảo sự đợt này đi nó
nằm xong em sandan chứ Phải sơn lót đấy
thì đây nó sẽ là
thế đoạn này nó sẽ xài đi này
em anh sẽ ở đây hay thôi Sắp trách ai đi
đến ở đây sẽ là một này đấy Đây là cũng
là một cũng được này thì đây xưa đến nay
đi là hai này
ông Long đây đúng không Ông Bình ở đây
đúng không được bạn
đây là cùng một ngày không còn ngày thứ
hai thì người khác học thì đấy là ông
Long cũng thể học nữa đúng không Đúng
rồi ok chưa Đúng rồi ok hiểu hiểu đoạn
này chưa ạ rồi
nhưng mà như này thì anh bảo rồi nó vẫn
có tình trạng là em Em không biết được
là lớp này đã được điểm lại ngày xưa Nếu
em chỉ biết hôm qua mỗi từ đây nói đi em
nói rồi này nữa không Không tốt lắm ở
địa và
đương nhiên là sự này đi em vẫn còn lưu
lại lát lại đi thì có nhưng mà thực tế
thì sinh viên này sau vẫn có thể chuyển
lớp nữa nên em vẫn phải lưu lại classid
trong này biết được là lớp Một lớp thì
ta điểm danh điểm danh cho cả lớp cô
sinh viên lớp hát được không sao cả lại
nói Thảo Như thế là lưỡi crest-audio
ngày cơ à
nhưng mà sau thấy nó trong tôi đừng có
rồi nhưng mà bây giờ chú nối xanh là
Hạnh nói thằng thằng này nữa cơ mà Đúng
không Đúng rồi ạ
Ừ
ok hiểu đấy à
nữa đấy
và nó sẽ ra ở đây Thằng thích cho em đi
có phải chính đâu nhá
Bởi vì thay phải sử dụng ta ngồi slot
này mất trách ai đi này flash ID này
date này bụi bạn bụng 4 thằng này nó
không cùng unique để tránh lặp lại ạ
đúng không nhiều hiệu Đợi Đấy chưa ạ
Chứ còn gì nữa nhỉ Thấy sơ đồ chúng nó
bị nhé
chia sẻ màn hình cho anh quên thử sơ đồ
chú với ạ
à à
ừ đúng rồi thì các bạn kia nói Ngài vẫn
gặp lại được
em alo để xem nhé hình như bị nhầm đấy
Cả ngày lặp lại không không không không
đúng rồi ngày lặp lại được thế nên mới
bảo là cùng slot về cùng bếp nó là nó là
unique nghĩa là trong cùng ngày ông đấy
nhưng mà học khóa K2 thì vẫn được vẫn
hợp lý mà Nhưng mà nếu lặp lại cùng cả
ngày cùng cả ca những sẽ bao lỗi
Đúng rồi bốn khuôn này nó cái chính vẫn
đúng mà á không phải quá trình như bốn
cục này cũng ngốn ít đúng mà
class là lập trình một này nếu mà giả sử
là đầy hai này có bị dạo này
khó A2 thì nó sẽ không sao còn nếu lặp
lại cái này một nó báo lỗi còn bất kỳ
cái gì Ví dụ này hay hay không sao cả
không lỗi gì cả à
các bạn ban Đông hiểu không nhỉ Ok ấy
con à
Anh không thấy gì của chú cần chữa âm
nhá Có code
khi cúp này là là quá và khóa học niên
khóa biểu cao vậy à
à Dựa theo clip chuẩn để biết được là nó
về học những môn nào đúng không Đúng rồi
gà Nếu thế nữa cái bất tiện được phải
không đất bất tiện ở đây à
là
lúc đầu lớp đấy sẽ chẳng biết ở học môn
nào cho anh khi chụp phân công
đi tìm thì Minh tiểu học theo thế chương
trình nào đó thì cứ phân công ra hết
Xong rồi chương trình đâu chương chương
trình khác chương trình chủ lưu lại ở
trong chương trình đúng không ngờ Có nối
gì để làm tới đâu
à lưu lại chứ gì nữa không chừa lại mây
chờ trong trong class chứ
tại flash
học sinh cùng lớp nhưng học khác ngày
nữa à
hết ý giao chủ cũng phải nối sửa xong ạ
còn cái gì nữa nhỉ Sắp cách lưu lại
Glass
môn học đúng rồi
hả Đúng rồi Sắp trách lưu lại nó vào
lúc này học môn này thì đúng là bạn
không
có phải cả trypsin nhé Cái sắp rách cơ à
anh sex ở
đây là bị bọn đấy
Em sắp rách lượng ra trẻ
không trả điểm gì cả Có lesson lưu đại
biết ở lớp mấy Học học môn đấy được đưa
ra từ bây giờ từ bây giờ biết được lớp
thấy học những môn nào rồi
nhưng cái này bị thừa tao bởi vì em
không thấy em nối với cái bạn nào hết
đấy là hoa thôi
mấy ông bạn thay đổi ý
anh ạ
Em sang đây nếu mà em ăn ngồi kiểu pít
chờ mà nói sao bây giờ kia chị ạ
em ạ
để đề xuất về sao giáo viên nào dậy được
những môn nào đúng không
Họ
có gì nói lại các bạn ấy nhé Ok trông nó
về rồi anh không có biết như nào chị
thấy đang hơi bị loạn ạ
anh chữa cho vào nhóm trước đó là kiểu
môn Đang lưu lại thẳng hàng luôn thì
thôi theo phong cách này cũng được về
sau sửa thì nó lằng nhằng hơn nó sẽ lặp
lại môn bây giờ sử có một môn mà thuộc
hai ngày sẽ phải tạo ra 2 môn
một môn thuộc 2 ngày chưa nghe thấy bao
giờ không có những cái môn cơ bản ngày
nào cũng phải học em chợ mới môn đại
cương được
anh có thể đại cương có thể là điển hình
giống như ở bên anh chuyên ngành này ví
dụ bây lập trình của bên anh cũng phải
học Nhập Môn mạng hả Ừ
giờ anh mở ốp cho chứ tao bây ông nào
giống như ông nào chồng buồn cười mỗi
ông có thể một cái ý tưởng riêng không
Sao lại nhờ tí về sau mấy ông sẽ thấy
mỗi cái ý tưởng Đấy nó sẽ sinh ra một
cái vấn đề
gì không nó sẽ có muốn những cái vấn đề
không không có một về đa bên là làm
chuẩn hoàn toàn cả anh từng nói rồi bây
giờ đã tới của em kéo ngày thì em sẽ đơn
giản được em không còn tại một bạn trung
gian để lưu lại việc ngành nào học môn
nào đấy đúng không đấy thì nó sẽ dễ việc
đấy nhưng mà nhiêu điểm mà em phải sinh
ra lắm môn có thể bị trùng nhau chứ còn
ở bên kia thì nó lại vì nó có bạn trung
gian nữa lại phải giải quyết kiểu khác
mỗi tháng có một cái yêu được
Anh ở chùa về sau các bạn cốt như thế
nào rồi
mày hơn hai tiếng rồi
chào các bạn nha Có gì Các bạn xem lại
buổi chiều âm bay và mong những bạn ngày
mai có xem hôm nay vậy mà kinh nghiệm
đúng không để mà mày biết cái trình bày
mai không biết được hai mươi mấy nhóm
tôi ngồi mà ở
ngoài chưa được 10 nhóm đâu rồi thế nhá
Chào bạn